So hello. Hello. This is not going to be a cold open. This is going to be a hot open. This is hot. Yeah. Let's make it hot. Let's give it a little bit of a summer theme on this hot open.
所以，你好。你好。这可不会是一个沉闷的开场。这将是一个火热的开场。这很火热。没错。让它火热起来吧。在这个火热的开场中，我们加点夏日的主题。
Oh, a summer. So here we are. So we're on the beach and oh, look at those waves. Beautiful. Is that a surfer out there? It looks like Will Arnett. Will, get on in here. We're doing a hot open.
哦，夏天。我们到了。我们在海滩上，哦，看那些海浪。太美了。那边有个冲浪的人吗？看起来像威尔·阿奈特。威尔，快过来。我们在做一个火热的开场。
Paddling in, he's paddling in. Hey, you guys cool with the G string? Yeah. Ah, it has no front. No, Will, don't turn around, don't turn around. Welcome to Smartless. Smartless. Smart.
正划着水过来，他正在划水过来。嘿，你们觉得G弦裤怎么样？啊，它没有前面。不，威尔，别转身，别转身。欢迎来到 Smartless。Smartless。Smart。
Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Um, Jay, did you sleep okay? I slept like a log.
Smart。Smart。Smart。Smart。Smart。Smart。Smart。Smart。Smart。Smart。Smart。嗯，杰伊，你昨晚睡得好吗？我睡得像死猪一样。
Yeah. Willie, you were missed last night. Lemon Bundt cake and Rice Krispies really put me down. We went back to the Bundt cake, huh? Whose was that? Was that yours, Seanny? No, that was a gift that somebody else brought in. Yeah, you were missed, Will.
是啊，威利，昨晚大家都很想念你。柠檬磅蛋糕和米脆饼真是让我大饱口福。我们又吃回磅蛋糕了，是吧？那是谁的？那是你的吗，肖尼？不，那是别人带来的礼物。对，大家都很想念你，威尔。
I missed it, yeah. I'm sorry I didn't come. I had a dinner with the boys. By boys, I mean my sons. Not with my golf buddies or something. Yeah, we had a nice, just my boys and me, which was really nice. That's nice, isn't it nice? Did you watch a movie?
我很想去，是的。我很遗憾没去。我和孩子们吃晚饭去了。我说的孩子们是指我的儿子们。不是和我的高尔夫球友什么的。对，我们过得很愉快，就我和我的儿子们，真的很棒。这很好，不是很棒吗？你们看电影了吗？
No, we watched a little Sunday night football, which was fun. All the snow. And then we did, sorry, so then we did do, we do movie night at night before bed. The littles like to watch a little movie. They call it movie night. Usually ends up being, put a movie on in my room
没有，我们看了一会儿周日night football，挺有意思的。到处都是雪。然后我们就，抱歉，然后我们确实做了，我们在睡前有电影之夜。小家伙们喜欢看一小会儿电影。他们叫它电影之夜。通常结果就是，在我的房间里放一部电影
on the bed and then it turns into fight. Everybody gets weapons. Oh yeah. You don't fall asleep right away? So last night, Daddy hadn't seen Star Wars and he kept saying, this is the real movie. We're like, I know, from moment one, he's like, what's he doing?
在床上，然后就变成了打仗。每个人都拿到武器。哦，对。你们没有马上睡着吗？所以昨晚，爸爸还没看过《星球大战》，他一直说，这才是真正的电影。我们就像，我知道，从一开始，他就说，他在干什么？
What's this guy doing? Are there any dead? He literally at one point goes, this is a great human, totally human pure moment. He goes, as C3P and R2D2 are walking on Tatooine, Sean, hold your boner. He goes, that's a desert? And we go, yeah. And he goes, there's no sea there.
这家伙在干什么？有人死吗？他 literalmente 甚至在某个时刻说，这是一个伟人，完全真实的人性时刻。他说，当C-3PO和R2-D2在塔图因上行走时，肖恩，管好你的小帐篷。他说，那是沙漠吗？我们说，是的。然后他说，那里没有海啊。
You go, no, he goes, I'm thirsty. It was so funny just right in that moment to say that. So anyway. Wait, but back to football. Yesterday I was watching football too and I don't understand why they, the guy, when they know they have a camera on them, they just hold one nostril and they blow it out
你说，没有，他说，我口渴了。在那个时候说出那样的话真是太搞笑了。所以无论如何。等等，但回到橄榄球。昨天我也在看橄榄球，我不明白为什么他们，那家伙，当他们知道有摄像机对着他们时，他们就按住一个鼻孔，然后往外擤
the other way. And it's so, they're always on camera just blowing their nose out. It's like, just get a Kleenex. Oh, you're right, they should go get Kleenexes on the side of the... Yeah, they hand them everything else. Excuse me, stop the play.
从另一边。而且太，他们总是在镜头前擤鼻涕。就像，去拿张纸巾。哦，你说得对，他们应该去……旁边拿纸巾。是的，其他什么东西他们都递。打扰一下，暂停比赛。
Excuse me, can I get a Kleenex? But why do they all spit in baseball too? I get that the chewing tobacco and stuff, but you know, only half the guys are chewing tobacco now. It's just, but it's like this weird like, I'm a male, check it out. I can spit. People on the street too that just like spit when they're like kind of uncomfortable
打扰一下，我能拿张纸巾吗？但为什么他们在棒球比赛里也都吐口水？我明白嚼烟草之类的，但你知道，现在只有一半的人在嚼烟草。这只是一种，但就像这种奇怪的，我是个男人，瞧我的。我会吐口水。街上的人也是，当他们觉得有点不舒服
or they know eyes are on them. It's like, yeah, I'm a dude. People on the fucking golf course do it. Guys, it's like you're not a real man, guy. We're just out here playing golf. I know. I was in Germany with Scotty on a vacation and I spit in public.
或者知道有目光注视着他们时，就会吐口水。就像，是的，我是一个纯爷们儿。该死的高尔夫球场上的人也这么干。伙计们，这就像你不是个真正的男人，老兄。我们只是出来打高尔夫球。我知道。我和斯科蒂在德国度假时，我在公共场合吐了口水。
He didn't talk to me the rest of the day. Yeah, like what's the matter with you? Yeah, we're on a huge fight. I just spit on the- Now you've got an escape valve, you know what I mean? If you think about it. But like why would, you know, you can swallow saliva. Like it's built for that.
他那天剩下的时间都不跟我说话了。对，就像你脑子有什么毛病？对，我们大吵了一架。我只是吐在——现在你有个泄压阀了，你知道我的意思吗？如果你想想的话。但为什么你会，你知道的，你可以把口水咽下去。就像它是为此而设计的。
Yeah, but if you have to get it out, what do you do? But exactly, but what saliva is so bad that you've got to get it out, put it on the ground? Here's an interesting thing. I was chewing tobacco, I get it. Here's the irony, is that knowing JB as well as I do, and you and I know him almost as well as anybody, he could go either way with that.
对，但如果你非得把它弄出来，你该怎么办？但准确地说，但口水到底有多糟糕，以至于你必须把它弄出来，吐在地上？这里有个有趣的事。我以前嚼烟草，我懂。这里讽刺的是，以我对JB的了解，你和我几乎和任何人一样了解他，他在这一点上可能会两边倒。
He could see somebody, work up like have some spit and swallow it and go, gross, why don't you just get rid of it? Why would you, am I right about that, James? Yes, I could argue both sides. That is so true. I know, it's so true, right? Do you think if I was a lawyer,
他可能会看到有人，酝酿一下，嘴里有点口水然后咽下去，然后说，真恶心，你为什么不把它弄掉？你为什么会，我说得对吗，詹姆斯？是的，我两边都可以辩论。太真实了。我知道，太真实了，对吧？你觉得如果我是个律师，
would I have been a defense attorney or a prosecutor? Both, you would have been both. Yeah. You would have come in, your honor, I'm representing both of you. Because I don't want anyone's involvement? No, and you don't want to be caught out being wrong in either way.
我会成为辩护律师还是公诉人？两者，你两者都会当。对。你会走进来，法官大人，我代表你们双方。因为我不想让任何人卷入？不，而且你不想被发现在任何一方面是错的。
So you're just like, I'm going to cover both. My dad does that. My dad goes, he'll say, he'll make a point, he'll go blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, and you're about, you go intake, you're about to make a point, and he'll go, having said that, and you're like, oh, you're going to argue the other side?
所以你就像，我要两头兼顾。我爸爸就这样。我爸爸会说，他会阐述一个观点，他会说，巴拉巴拉巴拉巴拉，然后你正要，你准备发表观点，他就会说，话虽如此，然后你就会想，哦，你要辩论另一面？
Yeah, yeah, yeah. We're going to make a point, and he'll go, having said that, and you're like, oh, you're going to argue the other side of the road? Yeah, yeah, yeah. Yeah, yeah, yeah. We're going to get to our guest right now, but Jason told, I've never heard that story unless you told it and I don't remember, and we don't have to tell it right now, but Jason was doing a play and he bought the cast. Oh my God, that story.
对，对，对。我们要阐述一个观点，然后他会说，话虽如此，然后你就会想，哦，你要辩论事情的另一面？对，对，对。对，对，对。我们现在要请出我们的嘉宾了，但杰森说，我从来没听过那个故事，除非你讲过而我不记得了，我们现在不一定要讲，但杰森当时在演一出戏，他给剧组买了个。哦，天哪，那个故事。
I was trying to remember what story I told you last night. God, it was so funny. I think I've said that on this before. Really? I don't remember. Just some horrible example of what a fucking monster I was in my early 20s. Did we talk about last time the thing
我当时在努力回想我昨晚跟你讲了什么故事。天哪，太搞笑了。我想我以前在节目里说过这个。真的吗？我不记得了。只是我二十出头时是个该死的怪物的一些可怕的例子。我们上次聊过那个
that we're not gonna talk about yet? We did, right? What's that? Yes, no, yeah, please don't even think about it. We did, right? What is that? I don't know, I'm just going home. The stuff that we're looking into doing with, did we?
我们还不能谈论的事情吗？聊过，对吧？什么？是的，不，是的，请甚至不要去想它。聊过，对吧？那是什么？不知道，我要回家了。我们正在考虑要做的那些事，聊过吗？
Oh, I don't know. You guys are in control of all in control. We didn't actually talk about it. Did we know words that that word we decided doing something We're really excited. We don't want to say yet, but we are excited About something because we've had we've had the three of us have talked to People have said to us like hey, you should do something with the brand as gross as that sounds. Very gross. And then, right for a while, we've sort of, and kind of like when we were thinking about going on tour,
哦，我不知道。你们掌控着一切。我们其实没聊过。我们知道那个词吗，我们决定做一件事我们非常兴奋。我们还不想说，但我们对某件事感到兴奋，因为我们已经，我们三个已经和人们聊过了，人们对我们说，嘿，你们应该围绕这个品牌做点什么，尽管听起来很粗俗。非常粗俗。然后，有一段时间，我们某种程度上，就像我们考虑去巡演时，
we were like, hey, should we do that blah, blah, blah. So then we were like, should we do something? And then we've sort of zeroed in on something that we are gonna do within the smart list world that we're really excited about. We can't really say, yet, I'm sorry, we're not sort of teasing it on purpose to not make you guess, but it is something that we are excited about
我们就在想，嘿，我们该做那个吗，巴拉巴拉。所以后来我们在想，我们该做点什么吗？然后我们把目标锁定在了一件我们要在smartless世界里做的事情上，我们对此非常兴奋。我们现在还不能说，抱歉，我们并不是故意卖关子不让你猜，但这确实是一件让我们感到兴奋的事情，
and when it finally comes to fruition. So kind of bear with us, but it's something pretty cool and that feels really organic to what we do. Right. Right. But first we're going to say hello. Yes. Ah, how about that? Yep. We're huge fans of our guest today,
当它最终实现的时候。所以请大家多多包涵，但这是一件相当酷的事情，而且对于我们所做的事情来说感觉非常自然。对。对。但首先我们要打招呼。是的。啊，怎么样？是的。我们今天嘉宾的超级粉丝，
not just his prolific work, but the man behind the empire is a dear friend to all of us. A self-proclaimed weird kid, his favorite holiday was Halloween. After graduating from Vassar, his career started as a real estate agent in Manhattan before working his way up at a major movie studio. Today he's a three-time Academy Award nominated,
不仅仅是因为他高产的作品，更是因为这个帝国背后的男人是我们所有人的挚友。他自称是个怪咖小孩，他最喜欢的节日是万圣节。从瓦萨学院毕业后，他的职业生涯始于曼哈顿的一名房地产经纪人，之后在一家大电影公司一路高升。如今他是三次奥斯卡金像奖提名者，
two-time Prime Time Academy Award winning, and a three-time Peabody Award winning producer. His company for which he is CEO and founder is considered the driving force in one of the last genres to get people into the theaters. He's our brilliant friend Jason Blum. Jason Blum of Blumhouse. Oh look at him.
两次黄金时段艾美奖得主，以及三次皮博迪奖得主制片人。他创立并担任首席执行官的公司被认为是让观众重返影院的最后几种类型片背后的驱动力。他是我们才华横溢的朋友杰森·布鲁姆。来自布鲁姆house的杰森·布鲁姆。哦，看他。
Oh, Blumhouse, hello there. Oh he's got his little warm jacket on. Look at him go. We're doing it, we're finally doing it. This is a very, very important day for me. This is, everybody just take it easy right now. Well, it's not probably the listeners who are as excited as I am.
哦，布鲁姆house，你好啊。哦，他穿着他那件小保暖夹克。看他那样的。我们在做了，我们终于在做了。这对我和说是一个非常非常重要的日子。这是，大家现在都放轻松点。好吧，可能听众没有我这么激动。
Because what I'd like to share with all your fans, by the way, I have, I guess like all your guests have been listening, the way not to sell your product is literally the last five minutes is exactly, you basically said we're doing something, someday we're going to tell you about it. I've never, I mean that was. We're stupid.
因为我想和你的所有粉丝分享的是，顺便说一句，我有，我想像你的所有嘉宾一样一直在听，推销你的产品的方式字面上的最后五分钟正是，你基本上说我们在做某事，总有一天我们会告诉你们。我从来没有，我的意思是那是。我们太蠢了。
It was, it was unbelievable, which is why, which is why I'm, which is why I'm very happy to be here to kind of help you with your chocolate bars, you know. Your chocolate bars. Well, it's just like, well, if you were like selling one of your movies, it's like buying a billboard and just having it just be black. We might make a scary movie, it might come out someday,
这真是，这真是难以置信，这就是为什么，这就是为什么我，这就是为什么我很高兴来到这里来帮你们推销巧克力棒，你知道的。你们的巧克力棒。好吧，这就像，如果你在推销你的某部电影，就像买一块广告牌然后把它弄成全黑的。我们可能会拍一部恐怖电影，它可能总有一天会上映，
and I'm not telling you what it's called. Yeah. Listen. What, so. By the way, effective. Yeah, but for my sister sister who may not know you, but knows the name of your company, Blumhouse, Blumhouse makes all the hit horror films you've ever seen
而且我不会告诉你它叫什么。听着。什么，所以。顺便说一句，很有成效。是的，但对于可能不认识你但知道你的公司名字Blumhouse的我的妹妹来说，Blumhouse制作了你见过的所有热门恐怖电影，这全都是因为你。外面的每一部恐怖电影基本上，每一部热门恐怖电影基本上都是Blumhouse出品的。你刚才说的是恐怖（horror），对吧？恐怖（horror），是的。恐怖（horror）。恐怖（horror）。恐怖（horror）。吓人。好吧。
and it's all because of you. Every horror film out there is basically, every hit horror film is basically a Blumhouse. You're saying horror, right? Horror, yeah. Horror. Horror. Horror. Scary. Okay.
是的，不过在我们开始谈论恐怖之前，我得先吐露点心里的事。恐怖（horror），对吧？恐怖（horror），是的。恐怖（horror）。恐怖（horror）。恐怖（horror）。吓人。是的，不过在我们开始谈论恐怖之前，我得先吐露点心里的事。我只是，因为你们真的很礼貌，我很感激，但我认为让你们数以亿计的听众知道我跟你们每个人都很熟是很重要的。是的。
Yeah, I just gotta get something off my mind first though before we start talking about horror. Horror, right? Horror, yeah. Horror. Horror. Horror. Scary. Yeah, I just got to get something off my mind first though before I start talking about horror. I just, because you guys are being really polite, which I appreciate, but I think it's important for all your gazillions of listeners to know that I know all of you individually. Yes.
我和杰森认识时间最长，但你知道，我们都有交情，我认为让大家知道，在过去，自从，Smartless开播多久了？两三年？五年？四年半。四年半了。
I've known Jason the longest, but you know, we have relationships and I think it's important for everyone to know that individually, over the last, since, how long has Smartness been? Two or three years? Five years? Four and a half. Four and a half years.
在过去的四年里，我大概总共发了15封邮件，每个人五封，每三四个月发一次，时间错开，恳求能上这个节目。错开时间。恳求。现在最严厉的回应是杰森根本不回复。很想在Smartless上宣传新电影，结果把我当空气。
I've probably over the last four years sent a total of 15 emails, five to each of you, every three or four months, timed separately, begging to be on the show. Timed separately. Begging. Now the harshest response is Jason just doesn't reply. Love to promote the new movie on SmartList, ghosting me.
不。不仅如此。我不这么觉得。我换了电子邮件地址。哪一个？不仅是邮件和短信，你还搞了单独的午餐、晚餐和集体晚餐。
No. Not only that. I don't think so. I changed my email address. Which one? Not only emails and texts, you also have done individual lunches, dinners, and collective dinners.
还有集体晚餐，对，对，对。午餐、集体晚餐，我家的每个人和我公司的每个人都知道这直是金圣杯。所以对L而言，我需要一点时间让这一切冲刷我。就像这是一个巅峰。忘掉那些愚蠢的奖项吧。这是一座山。
And a collective dinner, yes, yes, yes. Lunches, collective dinners, and everyone in my family and everyone in my company knows this has been the golden chalice. So for me, I just need a moment to let this wash over me. Like this is a pinnacle. Forget those dumb awards. This is a mountain.
我花了四年半时间想要攀登的山。泰德·萨兰多斯，如果你还记得，当他上节目时，我说，你得让他们现在就让我上。距离泰德上这个节目已经过去两年了。我喜欢布鲁姆说忘掉那些愚蠢的奖项。他没说忘掉钱，因为你永远不会忘掉钱。但有一件事。别忘了钱。布鲁姆，让我说布鲁姆说忘掉那些愚蠢的奖项，他没说忘掉钱，因为你永远不会忘掉
I've been trying to climb for four and a half years. The Ted Sarandos, if you remember, when he went on, I said, you gotta put, they're gonna put me on now. It's been two years since Ted's been on the show. I love that Blum said forget the dumb awards. He didn't say forget the money, because you never forget the money. But here's the one thing. Don't forget the money. Blum, let me say this Blum said forget the of the dumb awards He didn't say forget the money cuz you never forget
让我说，让我说忘掉钱，事实是永远别忘了钱。不，不，不，这是你认识杰森时间最长，但我们认识的时间比我们任何人都要早。哦，不，那是真的，在90年代中期，我们吃过一次饭，你把90%的时间都花在了东村外面的电话上，跟你的前老板通话。是的，被痛骂。被痛骂。另一件事是，我注意到，你穿着夹克，原因之一是
Let me say this let me say forget the money truth never forget the money No, no, no one is this you've you've known Jason the longest, but we met longer ago than any of us Oh, no, that's true in the mid 90s We had a dinner in which you spent 90% of it on the phone outside in the East Village with your former boss. Yes, being berated. Being berated. The other thing is, I noticed, you're wearing your jacket and one of the reasons is because
你一直在外面睡觉。对，等等，是的。我们来谈谈这个。仍然没有盈利。这是我的最爱。我一直，自从你向我展示了你的睡眠状况以来，布鲁姆，我对此着迷。人们会用“着迷”这个词，但我一直，自从你向我展示了你的睡眠状况以来，布鲁姆，我对此着迷。人们会用“着迷”这个词，但我字面意义上着迷了。
you've been sleeping outside. Yes, wait, yeah. Let's talk about that. Still not in profit. It's my favorite. I am still, since the moment you showed me your sleeping situation, Blum, I am obsessed with it. And people use obsessed, but I am still, since the moment you showed me your sleeping situation, Blum, I am obsessed with it. And people use obsessed, but I'm literally obsessed.
带我们了解一下。我也是。对。请带我们了解一下，如果可以的话。我奶奶住在北加利福尼亚的佩塔卢马，我们还在那儿，我在那儿还有个小房子，那是，我不知道是不是在有空调之前，但她没有空调，
Walk us through it. I am too. Yeah. Walk us through it, please, if you can. My grandmother lived in Northern California in Petaluma where we still, I still have this little house and it was, I don't know if it was before air conditioning, but she didn't have air conditioning,
他们有这种东西，我想在30年代和40年代，真正开始的时候，叫做露天睡眠平台（sleeping deck）。你只要在夏天放一张床垫在外面睡觉就能保持凉爽。当我去看望我奶奶时，我总是睡在露天睡眠平台上的睡袋里的小床垫上。从那以后，我一直想要一栋房子
and they had these things, I guess in the 30s and 40s, really is when it started, called sleeping decks. And you would just kind of put a mattress and sleep outside in the summer to stay cool. And when I went to go visit my grandmother, I used to always sleep outside on a little mattress in a sleeping bag on the sleeping deck. And ever since that time, I've always wanted a house
能让我睡在室外。大约五年前，我们在乡村峡谷买下了这栋房子，我在卧室外面建了一个平台。我们有一个完全带纱窗的门廊。没有暖气。我和我妻子每天晚上都在那儿睡。感觉太棒了。现在人们没有意识到，加利福尼亚，
where I could sleep outside. And about five years ago, we got this house in Rustic Canyon and I built a deck outside the bedroom. And we have a completely screened-in porch. There's no heat. And my wife and I sleep there every night. And it feels great. And now people don't realize, California,
其实真的会变得非常非常冷。嗯，晚上会变凉。是的。48华氏度、46华氏度差不多是最冷的时候。我戴着帽子睡觉。看到我的帽子了吗？我戴着帽子睡觉。我睡觉时，我有，你知道的，运动衫和运动裤，
it actually really does get really, really cold. Well, it gets cool at night. Yeah. 48, 46 is about the coldest that it gets. I sleep with a hat. See my hat? I sleep with the hat on. And I sleep with, I have, you know, sweats and sweatpants
我不戴手套。而且，而且，而且，而且你不需要白噪音机器，因为露天睡眠平台旁边就是个？一条小溪。有一条小溪。是的，你只需要用……所以我们能听到一条小溪。你只需要用那个。你有水，而且它就在圣莫尼卡的中央。
and I don't wear gloves. And, and, and, and, and you don't need a sound machine because right next to the sleeping deck is a? A creek. There's a little creek. Yes, you just use... So we hear a little creek. You just use that. You have water and it's right in the middle of Santa Monica.
我的意思是，太棒了。我对布鲁姆说，我——我们在那儿，他带我参观，我惊呆了，我说，作为一个加拿大人，我真的印象深刻。我说，我说，你怎么能在这外面睡觉？他说，好得不得了。对，我知道是那样的。
I mean, it's amazing. And I said to Blum, I go... And we were in there and he was showing me and I was just blown away and I go, especially as a Canadian, I was really impressed. And I said, I said, how do you sleep out here? And he goes, incredibly. Yeah. I know it's like that.
好得不得了。对。但接着他变本加厉地说。好得不得了，对。我的意思是，这是一个。但接着他变本加厉，因为你从那个冰冷的夜晚醒来后会立刻做什么？然后我走下去，那是一个带户外楼梯的阳台，我非常迅速地跳进我的冷水浴缸，
Incredibly. Yeah. But then he doubles down like. Incredibly, yeah. I mean, it's a. But then he doubles down, because what happens as soon as you wake up from that freezing night? Then I walk down, it's a balcony with an outdoor stairway and I do a jump in my cold plunge very quickly,
这很赶时髦也很可悲，但我做了。然后我洗个，然后我。在大概，37度？水温在37度，但我以前每天早上呆上一分钟，维维·尼沃呆上一分钟左右，我以前每天早上呆上一分钟，然后我开始生病。大概每两周我就会生不同的病，
which is very trendy and pathetic, but I do it. And then I take a, then I. It's at what, 37 degrees? It's at 37, but I used to stay in for a minute every morning, and Vivi Nivo stays in for a minute or something, and I used to stay in for a minute every morning, and then I started getting sick. Like every two weeks I was getting a different sickness,
我确信那是因为我一直在那样做。所以现在我只进去呆大概五秒钟，让我清醒过来，然后我跳进一个温暖的淋浴，然后我就去上学了。等等，难道这一切不能通过打开主卧室的窗户来解决吗？是的，只要打开窗户就行。完全不一样。
and I'm convinced it was because I was doing that. So now I just go in for like five seconds, wakes me up, and then I jump into a warm shower, and I'm on my way to school. Now, couldn't all of this be solved by just opening the windows in your main bedroom? Yeah, just open the windows. Not the same at all.
完全不一样。哦，完全不一样。完全不一样。完全不一样，完全不一样。因为每隔一段时间，我们在开着所有窗户的卧室里睡觉，就是，感觉不一样。劳伦也完全支持这一切。她也做冷水浴吗？
Not the same. Oh, not at all. Not the same. Not at all, not at all. Because every so often, we sleep in the bedroom with all the windows open, it's just, it's not the same. And Lauren's on board with all this. Does she do the cold plunge too?
她不做冷水浴，但她喜欢睡在室外，我们每天晚上一起睡在室外。她不做冷水浴，但……肖恩，你以前睡在室外，对吧？抱歉，在Five Guys外面。每次他们新开一家Five Guys，你都会睡在外面。
She does not do the cold plunge, but she loves sleeping outside, and we sleep outside together every too? She does not do the cold plunge, but she loves sleeping outside and we sleep outside together every night. She doesn't do the cold plunge, but... Sean, you used to sleep outside, right? Sorry, a Five Guys. Every time they open a new Five Guys, you'd sleep outside.
等到它开门。对，我太激动了。我会把自己饿瘦。现在杰森，这种古怪不仅仅止于此。让我们来谈谈，向特雷西解释一下洛杉矶的交通状况和停车状况，以及你是如何设法绕过这个问题的。好的，但在那之前，是的，我想听那个，
Wait until it's open. Yeah, I got so excited. I'd starve myself. Now Jason, the eccentricities don't stop there. Let's talk to, let's explain to Tracy about the traffic situation and the parking situation in Los Angeles and how you've managed to circumvent that problem. Right, but before that, and yes, I want to hear that,
我只想告诉特雷西，你知道的，潜伏、灵动：鬼影实录、人类清除计划、逃出绝命镇，等等等等，我只是想让大家，让人们坐稳了。这些是杰森制作的电影，你是这个意思吧。没，就是这样。没错，没错。是的，他负责了所有这些。
I just want to tell Tracy, like, you know, insidious, paranormal activity, the purge, get out, it goes on and on and on, I just want to let, get people off the seat. These are films that Jason has produced, is what you're trying to say. That's right, that's right. Yeah, he's responsible for all of these.
对，对，对。分裂、万圣节，你漏掉了几个大的，玩具熊的五夜后宫，梅根。没错，没错。是的，那是演员。他负责了所有这些。对，对，对。分裂、万圣节，你漏掉了几个大的，玩具熊的五夜后宫，梅根。没错。你漏掉了几个大的。礼物，杰森参演的那部，对吧？最重要的是，礼物。但我说这一切是因为你可以完成这一切
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Split, Halloween, you left on a couple big Five Nights at Freddy's, Megan. That's right, that's right. Yeah, that's the actor. He's responsible for all of these. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Split, Halloween, you left out a couple big Five Nights at Freddy's, Megan. That's right. You left out a couple of big ones. The gift, which Jason was in, right? Most importantly, the gift. But I say all that because you can accomplish all this
因为，对于杰森的问题，你有一辆？一辆面包车。一辆面包车。这就是你在说的事吗？你开着到处跑的那辆。一辆面包车，一辆面包车。我对效率有着执念。我对效率有着执念。我对此着迷。
because, to Jason's question, you have? A van. A van. Is that what you're talking about? That you drive around in. A van, a van. I'm obsessed with efficiency. I'm obsessed with efficiency. I'm obsessed with it.
是的。我非常执着的一件事是，我一直对在洛杉矶的生活感到有些挣扎。不管，你知道，我对洛杉矶一直是忽冷忽热的。但有一件我真的很不喜欢的事情就是开车、交通、代客泊车、找停车位以及所有这些事情。
Yes. And one of the things I was very fixated on is I've always kind of struggled with life in LA. And whether, you know, I always, I was very hot and cold in LA. But one of the things I really don't like is driving and traffic and valet parking and parking and all of that stuff.
我真的更喜欢公共交通。有一段时间我住在市中心，我在洛杉矶坐地铁。我可以坐优步。这是在洛杉矶。嗯，它直接通往市中心，所以你坐优步到圣莫尼卡的车站，然后坐火车，然后我可以步行回家。
I really much prefer public transportation. There was a while when I lived downtown that I took the subway in LA. I could take an Uber. This is in LA. Well, it went right downtown, so you take an Uber to the stop in Santa Monica and then take the train and then I could walk to my house.
哇。这是一种非常“洛杉矶”的方式来坐地铁。不过，最棒的是。这辆面包车。我是第二代面包车，但我一直说如果我拍了一部热门电影，我要为自己做这个。我的第一个热门作品是《灵动：鬼影实录》，
Wow. That's a very LA way to take the subway. But anyway, the best thing. This van. And I'm in my second generation of van, but I always said if I made a hit movie, I was going to do this for myself. And the first hit I had was Paranormal Activity,
我立刻就行动了。我花1万美元给自己买了一辆旧的雪佛兰Astro。在那个时候，大概12年左右，很少有底盘平坦的小型面包车，就像杂工开的那种。所有的小型面包车后桥都有一个凸起。我明白。所以这辆车完全是平的，于是我们买了一辆面包车，我把它带给一个做汽车音响的家伙，给了他，我想，2万美金？我觉得整下来一共3万美元。他在后面建了一个办公室，
and I went right out. I bought myself a used Chevy Astro for $10,000. Now at that time, this is about 12 years ago, there were very few minivans with a flat bottom, like a handyman. All of the minivans had a hump for the back axle. I understand. So this was completely flat and so we took a minivan and I took it to a guy who did car stereos and gave him, I think, 20 grand? I think the whole thing was 30,000 bucks. And he built an office in the back,
所以我有一台电脑，我有一个键盘，我有一台打印机。太疯狂了。而且屏幕可以上下升降，所有的窗户都关上，这样我就不可能在后座指手画脚，所以我永远不会说，比如，我绝不会去想，我希望你走这条路线或那条路线，或者这里的交通还是那里的交通。因为如果你在你的小天地里工作，
so I had a computer, I had a keyboard, I had a printer. That's crazy. And the screen went up and down, all the windows closed, so I would make it impossible for myself to backseat drive, so I would never say, like, I would never think about, I wish you were going this route or this route or the traffic here or the traffic there. Because if you're in your thing and you're working,
花20分钟还是30分钟都无所谓。它现在就像一辆Waymo。就像一辆Waymo，完全如此。所以你在处理电话，你在看剪辑粗剪，你在接收传真。我在看剪辑粗剪，我在处理电子邮件，我在打印登机牌，
it doesn't matter if it takes 20 minutes, if it takes 30 minutes. It's like a Waymo now. It's like a Waymo, exactly. So you're rolling calls, you're watching cuts, you're receiving faxes. I'm watching cuts, I'm doing my email, I'm printing out my boarding pass,
你可以打印你的小演讲稿，我在打印我的登机牌。你可以打印你的小演讲稿，我在打印我的演讲稿。然后如果你需要在某处停车而没有停车位，你在这辆面包车的侧面喷了什么？哦，我做了，我喷了。它是一辆电工的面包车，但上面写着“电工”。哦，商业住宅电工，是的。所以它看起来像个电工。Blum power写着电工，哦，商业住宅电工，是的。
you could print out your little speech, I'm printing out my boarding pass. You could print out your little speech, I'm printing out my speech. And then if you need to park somewhere and there's no parking, what you did was you painted on the side of this van what? Oh, I did, I painted. It was an electrician van, but it said electric. Oh, commercial residential electrician, yeah. So it looked like an electrician. Blum power said electric, oh commercial residential electrician, yeah.
所以它看起来像个电工。Blum power之类的。Blum power，对，完全如此。它看起来像一辆商用车辆。它看起来像个商业小杂工，看起来像个杂工。对，一个路锥你就搞定了。你知道谁以前那么干吗？
So it looked like an electrician. Blum power or something like that. Blum power, yeah exactly. It looked like a commercial vehicle. It looked like a commercial little handyman, it looked like a handyman. Yeah, one cone and you're good. You know who used to do that?
你知道谁以前经常这么干而且非常有效吗？就是斯塔西，这个德国的秘密警察，他们会开着一辆看起来像面包车的车到处转悠，把人从街上抓起来塞进后备箱，然后带到斯塔西总部，也就是审讯室。你知道我的意思吗？所以这个……
You know who used to do that a lot and was really effective for, was the Stasi, the secret police in this Germany, and they would drive around and it would look like a bread truck and they would nab people off the street and stuff them in the back and then take them to the Stasi headquarters, the torch room. You know what I mean? So this is...
第二部分是一部电影。我们可不是来真的。对，没错。我其实在加油站从小贩的面包车后面买过音响。我真的买过。那可能就是改装我面包车的那个人。他车底是平的吗？而且它们不是真的。
The second part is a movie. We don't do that for real. Yeah, right. I actually bought speakers out of the back of some guy's van at a gas station. I did. That could have been the guy who redid my van. Did he have a flat bottom? And they were not real.
它们是……不，否则就没意思了。而且它们不是真的，对吧？它们是假的，是空的，对吧？对，是空的，完全空的。现在杰森，你说你对洛杉矶的挣扎，那暗示你来自别处，那是哪里？嗯，我在洛杉矶出生，我在这儿住到五岁，
They were... No, otherwise it wouldn't have been interesting. And they weren't real, right? They were fake, they were empty, right? Yeah, they were empty, totally. Now Jason, you say your struggles with LA, that implies you came from somewhere, where is that place? Well, I was born in LA, I lived here till I was five,
然后在纽约长大。我长大直到八年级，我在韦斯特切斯特多布斯费里的公立学校上学，年级。我在韦斯特切斯特多布斯费里的公立学校上学。然后我去康涅狄格州上了寄宿学校，那非常具有创伤性。然后我去了波基普西的瓦萨学院。然后我住在纽约。在我电影生涯的头十年里，
and then I grew up in New York. I grew up until eighth grade, I went to public school in Dobbs Ferry in Westchester, grade. I went to public school in Dobbs Ferry in Westchester. And then I went to boarding school in Connecticut, which was very traumatic. And then I went to Vassar and Poughkeepsie. And then I lived in New York. For my first 10 years of motion picture shenanigans,
我在90年代住在纽约。我1991年毕业，所以我从91年呆到2000年。然后我在2000年搬到洛杉矶，我一直考虑搬回去，但我从来没有真正搬。但你刚搬到洛杉矶时，你暗示你住在市中心。有一段时间，你住在酒店里。
I lived in New York in the 90s. I graduated in 1991, so I was there from 91 to 2000. And then I moved to LA in 2000, and I've always thought about moving back, but I never really have. But when you first moved to LA, you alluded to the fact that you lived downtown. For a while, you lived in a hotel.
你从来不想定居。我住在丽思卡尔顿。对，太棒了。我到现在还拥有那套公寓，如果有人想买的话。我他妈的怎么也卖不掉那套房子。不过湖人队比赛之类的交通怎么办呢？比如当他们在建加密货币网球馆
You never wanted to commit. I lived at the Ritz. Yeah, it was great. I love it. I still own the apartment, if anyone wants to buy. I cannot sell that thing for the life of me. What about the traffic about Laker games and stuff, though? Like when they were building crypto
或者斯台普斯中心之类的时候。哦，湖人队比赛的时候太棒了，因为我有很好的停车位。我可以把车停在我家。好吧。好吧，我其实不怎么去看湖人队的比赛，但我可以去斯台普斯中心看演出。是的，但你进不去也出不来。对，我喜欢。
or Staples or whatever. Oh, Laker games was amazing because I had great parking. I could just park at my house. Right. Well, I didn't really, I don't really go to the Lakers, but I could go to Staples to see shows. Yeah, but you couldn't get in and out. Yeah, I loved it.
太棒了。这很少见。你知道如果他跟你一起出门是什么意思。我明白你的意思。比如如果我回来的时候正好赶上湖人队的比赛，是的，有时确实挺烦人的。也没那么糟，没那么糟。现在你难道不怀念，听起来太理想了，
It was great. It was rare. You know what you mean if he was going out with you. I know what you mean. Like if I was coming back and there was a Lakers game, yeah, sometimes it was a game in the ass. It wasn't that bad, it wasn't that bad. Now do you not miss, it just sounds so ideal,
首先，我看过瓦萨学院的校园，美得不可思议。我只能想象康涅狄格州的寄宿学校也同样 gorgeous。当你搬到洛杉矶时，你难道不怀念——因为我们在洛杉矶的冬天录制这期节目，这里的树叶终于开始变色了，
first of all, I've seen the Vassar campus and it's incredibly beautiful. I can only imagine the boarding school in Connecticut was also gorgeous. When you moved out here to Los Angeles, did you not miss, because we're recording this in the wintertime here in LA, and it's just, the leaves are finally turning,
但东海岸一年大部分时间都是那样的。你难道不怀念这一切吗？对，我想念，这就是我说的。我在洛杉矶生活得很挣扎，我非常想念它。夏天我们在康涅狄格州。我和我妻子达成了一个协议。我妻子比较喜欢洛杉矶，但我们达成协议，每逢学校假期我们就去东海岸。
but it's like that most of the year in back east. Do you not miss all of that? Yes, I miss, that's what I'm saying. I struggle with living in LA, I miss it terribly. We're in Connecticut for the summer. I made a deal with my wife. My wife kind of prefers LA, but we made a deal that when school holidays we go to the East Coast.
所以整个夏天我都能在东海岸度过。但你在洛杉矶住的地方感觉就像东海岸。树木繁茂，很有森林的感觉。确实如此。我们马上回来。现在回到节目中。你知道吗？因为你当过房地产经纪人，这太搞笑了，顺便说一句，我以前不知道。哈？等等，什么？
So for all summer I get to be on the East Coast. But where you live in LA feels like the East Coast. Very wooded, foresty. That's true. We'll be right back. And now back to the show. You know what? Because you're a real estate agent, that's so funny by the way, I didn't know that. Huh? Wait, what?
他当过房地产经纪人。我曾经是一名持牌房地产经纪人。什么时候？在纽约。我在1992年、1993年为Chromon Real Estate工作过，是的，那是一份相当棒的工作。在纽约市？在纽约市。那是在我卖有线电视之后。我先是挨家挨户推销有线电视，纯提成，
He was a real estate agent. I was a licensed real estate agent. When? In New York. I did it for Chromon Real Estate, 1992, 1993, yeah, it was an amazing job. In New York City? In New York City. That was after I sold cable TV. First I sold cable TV door to door, commission only,
我每卖一单赚29块钱，就是这样，只有你把有线电视卖给别人你才能赚钱。为时代华纳？在芝加哥，不，芝加哥Prime Cable。是吗？芝加哥Prime Cable。我喜欢纯提成的职业，这就是为什么，电影也是一样的。
I made 29 bucks a sale, that's it, you only made money if you sold someone cable TV. For Time Warner? In Chicago, no, Prime Cable of Chicago. Yeah? Prime Cable of Chicago. I loved commission only jobs, and that's why, and the movies are the same thing.
我的电影不拿固定薪水。只有电影成功了，我才能拿到钱。这从我很小的时候就开始了，你知道，比如铲车道上的雪，其实铲车道就是一个很好的例子，如果我给园林绿化工打工，你每小时只能挣，你知道的，五块钱，或者你可以去铲车道然后说，
I don't get paid on our movies. I only get paid if the movies work. And that started when I was really young, you know, doing shoveling driveways, and actually shoveling driveways is a good example of it, is if I had to work for a landscaper and you get like, you know, five bucks an hour, or you could go shovel driveways and say,
好吧，我帮你铲完整条车道，给我10块或15块钱。我一直，我讨厌拿那种固定工资或计件工资。我总是喜欢为我实际完成的工作拿报酬。对。对。所以当其他所有人都在当服务员时，我去卖有线电视，因为我想，我可以赚更多钱，只要按销售额付我钱就行。
well, do your whole driveway, give me 10 bucks or 15 bucks. And I always, I hated getting paid always like a salary work for hire. I always liked getting paid for the exact work that I did. Right. Right. So when everyone else was a waiter, I sold cable because I'm like, I can make more money, if just pay me for the sales.
房地产也是一样，当其他所有人都在当房地产经纪人时，因为你只有在帮别人租下公寓时才能拿到钱。我一直喜欢销售。这太酷了，太疯狂了。我依然喜欢销售。因为你拥有那个人，你拥有那种，你的个性太有魅力了
And the same thing with the real estate, when everyone else was a real estate agent, because you only got paid if you rented people apartments. And I always loved sales. That's cool, that's wild. I still love sales. Because you have the person, you have that, you're such an amazing personality
以至于我想知道你是否，那段经历对你的成长有什么帮助，以及你是什么时候转行做制片人的？因为你那么，你那么有亲和力，每个人都喜欢你。是的。谢谢你，在你转行做制片人时，因为你那么有亲和力，每个人都喜欢你。是的。谢谢，谢谢。我总是说，我受过的最好的制片人培训就是房地产，
that I wondered if you, how did that kind of age you and when you crossed over to producing? Because you're such, you're so personable, everybody loves you. Yeah. Thank you in when you crossed over to producing because you're so personable, everybody loves you. Yeah. Thank you, thank you. The best, I always say that I think the best training I ever got for being a producer was real estate
因为这和当演员一样，你一直在被拒绝。所以大多数人没有租下公寓，对吧？大多数电影你都没拍成。所以这让你非常习惯于被拒绝，你只需要继续尝试。非常类似于表演，你必须不断尝试，不断尝试。然后它成功了，这就是销售。
because it's the same as being an actor, you get rejected all the time. So most people don't rent the apartment, right? Most movies you don't get, most movies you don't get made. So it got you very, it gets you very used to being rejected and you just got to keep trying. Very similar to acting, you got to keep trying and keep trying. And then it works, it's sales.
这个行业的每个环节都是销售，除非你在电影公司工作并且处于买方端。但即使是他们，他们也在推销一种直接的东西，他们想要，电影公司的人也是销售。他们在推销，他们希望导演去拍他们不一定想拍的东西。他们希望演员去演他们不一定想演的戏，对吧？
Every part of this business is sales unless you save a studio job and you're on the buying side. But even them, they're selling a direct, they're trying to, studio people are salespeople too. They're selling, they want directors directing they don't necessarily want to do. They want actors to do things they don't necessarily want to act in, right?
他们希望他们的老板去拍一部老板不一定想拍的电影。是的，每首歌。每个人都在销售，在某种程度上每个人都在销售。而且你们公司现在这么大了，你既在做销售，又同时在买入和卖出，对吧？是的，我们一直在买入，试图向你推销某种创意，你必须做出决定，你喜欢在两者之间来回切换吗？我喜欢，我喜欢。我喜欢在买入之间来回切换
They want their boss to make a movie their boss doesn't necessarily want to make. Yeah, every song. Everyone's selling, everyone's selling to a certain degree. And your company's so big now you're doing both sales and you're buying and selling at the same time, right? Yeah we do buy in all the time trying to sort of sell you a pitch on something and you've got to make a decision and Do you like toggling back and forth between that? I do I do I like toggling back and forth buying
你会不会去做一个贴纸，上面写着“我喜欢切换”，我宁愿切换。我宁愿切换。我其实想把它喷在我的面包车上。我喜欢被切换。我跟杰森一样，我喜欢两头兼顾。我喜欢两头兼顾。切换电工。切换电工。
I would you get a bumper sticker that says I like to toggle I'd rather be toggling. I'd rather be toggling. I'd actually paint that on my van. I like to be toggled. I'm like Jason, I like to do both sides. I like to do both sides. Toggling electric. Toggling electric.
切换电工。切换电工。失落已久的开关。让我问你这个。好吧，我想探讨一下这个。目前的情况是怎样的，你和我以前讨论过这个。我说，好吧，我们可以拍一部喜剧吗，
Toggling electric. Toggling electric. The long lost switch. Let me ask you this. Okay, I want to get into this. What is the current, you and I have talked about this before. I said, well, can we do a comedy,
我记得大约一年半前左右我们吃过午餐，我说，我们可以拍，做一部喜剧吗？你说，那里面没钱可赚。我说，真的吗？我的意思是，实际上你就是这么说的。电影的现状。里面没有我的钱。
I remember about a year and a half ago or something we had lunch and I said, can we do, make a comedy? You said, there's no money in it. And I said, really? I mean, in effect you said that. The state of movies. There's no money for me in it.
里面没有你的钱。对，是的。不，不，我懂了，别担心。你没有拿片酬。你直到中午才拿片酬。我懂了。我没有拿，我不是喜剧演员。是的，不，不，我懂了，别担心。你直到纽约才拿片酬。我懂了。我没有拿片酬，我不是喜剧演员。是的，不，不，我懂了，我读过那个。
There's no money for you in it. Right, yeah. No, no, I got it, don't worry. You're not getting paid. You're not getting paid until noon. I got it. I'm not getting, I'm not the comedian. Yeah, no, no, I got it. Don't worry. You're not getting paid until New York. I got it. I'm not getting paid, I'm not the comedian. Yeah, no, no, I got it, I read that.
但从你的角度来看，目前这个星球上院线电影的现状是怎样的？人们还能拍它们吗？它们能赚钱吗？人们还想去看吗？好吧，让我们澄清一下记录。关于喜剧，我的回答不是，我在里面赚不到钱，尽管这确实是真的，
But what is the state of theatrical films on this planet right now from your perspective? Can people still make them? Can they make money? Do people want to go and see them? Okay, let's just clear the record. On the comedy, my response was not, I can't make money in it, although that is true,
但我们不做喜剧的原因是因为你，我不知道，我认为恐怖片真的很奏效，院线恐怖片不需要庞大无比的明星。是的，因为这关乎创意。电视则不同，电视喜剧则不同，但对于喜剧，对于恐怖片。电视不同。电视喜剧不同。但对于喜剧，对于一部喜剧要想起作用，
but the reason that we don't do comedy is because you, I don't, I think horror really works, you don't need massive, massive stars for theatrical horror. Yeah, because it's about the idea. TV, different thing, TV comedy, different thing, but for comedy, for a horror. TV, different thing. TV comedy, different thing. But for comedy, for a comedy to work,
喜剧要在电影院里起作用非常难。有那么多伟大的喜剧。你们所有人都在电视上参与过很多。恐怖片在电视上其实不太行。电视上有大量优秀的喜剧。所以要创作，而且喜剧要在院线上映起作用，我依然觉得非常难，而且你需要一个超级大明星，
comedy is just very hard to work in movie theaters. There's so much great comedy. All of you guys have been part of a lot of it on television. Horror doesn't really work on TV. There's a lot of great comedy on TV. So to make, and for comedy to work theatrically, I still think it's very hard anyway, and you need a huge star
以至于成本变得很高。正如你所知的，曾经有一段时间。我不喜欢拍昂贵的电影。正如我们所知，曾经有一段时间，尤其是在21世纪初，有大量由大明星驱动的大制作喜剧电影。但正如我们所知，尤其是如果我们回头看其中的很多电影，我一直坚持认为
so that it becomes expensive. And there was a time as you know. I don't like making expensive movies. As we know, there was a time, especially in the early aughts where there were a ton of big comedy films driven by big stars. But as we know, especially if we go back and look at a lot of them, I've always maintained
拍一部好的喜剧电影很难，因为电影制作的本质并不利于那种惊喜的元素等等。在电视里，你必须快速制作，你必须不断推进，所以喜剧在那方面行得通。拍电影通常会很枯燥而且相当无聊，A，这是其一。
it's hard to make a good comedy film because of the nature of making film does not lend itself to that element of surprise, et cetera. In television, you have to make it quickly, you have to keep moving, and so it works for comedy in that way. Making movies, it can be often tedious and quite boring, A, that's one.
拍一部好的喜剧电影很难，因为电影制作的本质不利于那种突发奇效等元素。在电视界，你必须快速制作，不断推进，所以这种方式适合喜剧。而拍电影往往既繁琐又相当无聊，首先，这是其一。
But, so it's funny that comedy works on TV and horror does not and vice versa. But what about the state of theatrical movies, of film? Well, this is constantly on my mind. And I actually texted, I texted Aaron this morning, who runs all the AMC theaters, because they had their biggest weekend ever. Right.
但有意思的是，喜剧在电视上管用，恐怖片不管用，反之亦然。但说到院线电影的现状，也就是电影本身？好吧，这一直盘旋在我的脑海里。其实我今天早上还发短信给亚伦，就是运营所有AMC影院的那位，因为他们刚迎来了史上最卖座的周末。没错。
And I keep trying, I've been asking everyone, I trust on that, like, is this like an anomaly, or do you think? Yeah, but look at what worked. It's Wicked, which was an IP already established for 20 years. There's Gladiator 2, which was a massive movie. Moana, which was an institution in and of itself.
而且我一直在尝试，我一直在问我信任的所有人，比如，这只是一场特例，还是你觉得？对，但看看什么片子火了。是《魔法坏女巫》，这是一个已经建立20年之久的知名IP。还有《角斗士2》，这是一部大制作电影。还有《海洋奇缘》，它本身就是一个金字招牌。
Two sequels. Well, that's different. If you're saying, people don't want original movies. They don't. Like, they say that they want them, but actions speak louder than words. That's right. People want the reason they're all sequels and remakes,
两部续集。好吧，那不一样。如果你说的是，人们不想要原创电影。他们确实不想要。就像，他们嘴上说想要，但事实胜于雄辩。没错。人们想要的——这就是为什么全都是续集和翻拍，
that that's what they want. That's what the audience is showing up to that consistently, consistently, consistently, and even more so now, if you look at horror this year, one horror movie in 12 months really hit. Original. There were six or seven sequels that worked, but one original horror.
这才是他们真正想看的。观众一而再、再而三、再而三地涌向影院的就是这种电影，现在更是如此。如果你看看今年的恐怖片，12个月里真正火了一部恐怖片。原创的。有六七部续集表现不错，但原创恐怖片只有一部。
I don't think you'd have to go long legs. I want to see that. I think you'd have to go long legs. Long legs. I want to see that. I think you'd have to go back ten years for... For... To see where only one original horror movie worked. I mean, it's... Have there been any outliers in terms of films that... Horror and or otherwise that have done well in the last, let's say,
我觉得你得去看看《长腿》。我想看那部。我觉得你得去看看《长腿》。《长腿》。我想看那部。我觉得你得回溯十年去寻找……为了……去看看到底哪里只有一部原创恐怖片大获成功。我的意思是，这……有没有什么非同寻常的电影，不管是恐怖片还是其他类型的电影，在过去的，比方说，
since the pandemic, since 2020, in the last four and a half years? Anything? Well, yeah, our high Five Nights at Freddy's was last year, it was our highest grossing movie of all time. Wow. And that was the original?
自从大流行以来，自2020年以来，在过去的四年半里？有什么吗？哦，对，我们的《玩具熊的五夜后宫》是去年上映的，它是我们有史以来票房最高的电影。哇。那那是原创的吗？
No, it's based on a game. Based on an IP, yeah. But based on a game. Based on a game, yeah, yeah, yeah. But that did 300 million bucks. I'm trying to think. We had our best, Megan was one, Megan was a huge movie, Black Phone was a huge movie,
不，它是根据游戏改编的。基于一个IP，对吧。但它是根据游戏改编的。根据游戏改编的，对，对，对。但那部赚了三亿美元。让我想想。我们有我们最棒的，《梅根》是一部，《梅根》是一部大热电影，《黑色电话》是一部大热电影，
Quiet Place is not our movie, huge movie, Conjuring. Those were post, Quiet Place was this year, those were all post-pandemic. Horror franchises are, like I said, we had our Insidious Five last year, it was the highest grossing Insidious movie of all five of them. And that was last year.
《寂静之地》不是我们的电影，但也超级卖座，《招魂》。那些都是大流行之后上映的，《寂静之地》是今年上映的，这些全都是大流行之后的作品。恐怖片系列就像我说的，我们去年推出了《潜伏5》，它是全部五部《潜伏》电影中票房最高的一部。那是去年的事。
And it was the most insidious most I'm sure you've seen all five of the fire So hey so Jason without getting too much into the weeds for for folks like Tracy Can you speak what do you think the current appetite is in the business for these sort of these trick deals where instead of an actor getting paid a bunch of money up front, like when you're talking about this scenario with comedy
而且它也是最阴险的……我敢肯定你已经看过全部五部火爆的电影了。所以，嘿，杰森，咱们别扯得太远，对于像特雷西这样的人来说——你能谈谈，你认为目前业内对于这种巧妙交易的胃口如何？也就是演员不拿一大笔前期片酬，就像你刚才提到的喜剧片那样，
where by having a big star in there, it becomes sort of cost prohibitive. But I think some actors, Cameron Diaz is one of the famous ones that did it for a teacher. Bad teacher. A bad teacher where she basically didn't take a lot of money up front, but then had this definition
由于大牌明星的加盟，导致成本高得让人吃 prohibitive（让人望而却步）。但我认为有些演员，卡梅隆·迪亚兹就是其中一位有名的代表，她为了某部作品这么做过。坏老师。坏老师里她基本上没拿多少前期片酬，但她有这样一种定义：
for the back end of a profit participant where if the film did really well, she got paid a lot of money and she did. Because I know your model, without getting into stuff you may or may not want to talk about, you seem to be open to this type of structure in the interest of trying to get as many at-bats as possible in the hopes of finding a great movie.
作为利润分成的后端，如果电影票房大卖，她就能赚到大笔钱，而她也确实拿到了。因为我知道你的模式，抛开你可能想谈或不想谈的东西不谈，为了尽可能多地获得击球机会，以期找到一部好电影，你似乎对这种结构持开放态度。
Well, no, it's more than that. That's our main tenant of our entire business is no one gets paid up front, including us. Just like my real estate and just like my cable TV, no one gets paid, or you get paid minimum scale, and if the movie works okay, you get paid minimum scale and if the movie works okay, you get paid okay and if the movie works really well, you should get paid more than you've ever made before.
嗯，不，不仅如此。这是我们整个业务的核心租金——没有人能拿到前期片酬，包括我们自己在内。就像我的房地产和我的有线电视一样，没有人拿报酬，或者你只拿最低标准酬劳，如果电影表现一般，你就拿最低标准酬劳；如果电影表现还行，你就拿还行的酬劳；如果电影票房大爆，你拿到的钱应该比你以往赚过的任何一笔都要多。
That's our whole, I wrote. What about your toggle business? The toggle business is also an if come business by the way. It's a fantastic if come business. Yes. But I remember you saying that, I remember you Blum talking about, and who I won't name, but an actor
这就是我们的全部，我写过。那你的Toggle业务呢？Toggle业务顺便说一句也是一种“如果达成则支付”的业务。这是一个棒极了的“如果达成则支付”的业务。是的。但我记得你说过，我记得你——布伦谈到过，虽然我不会点名，但有一位演员，
who was in one of your films in the last five, 10 years, who's a well-known actor, who you said, they made more money doing this. They took nothing up front. They made more money doing this than they'd made on anything else. They'd ever done. Yeah, that's true.
在过去五、十年里参演过你的一部电影，是个很有名的演员，你说过，他们通过这种方式赚的钱更多。他们前期一分钱没拿。他们通过这种方式赚到的钱，比他们拍过的任何其他作品都要多。他们以前做过的任何东西。是的，千真万确。
That's true. And that's how we keep getting people to work for us and take a gamble. And you didn't mind doing that, right? You didn't mind writing those checks to that actor. The greatest thing I can ever do is if I write the biggest check to anyone's ever made on my... That means a gun law.
千真万确。这就是我们如何不断吸引人们为我们工作并愿意冒险的方式。你当时很乐意这么做吧？你很乐意给那个演员开那些支票。我能做过的最棒的事，就是给任何在我手下工作过的人开出史上最大的一张支票……这意味着这是一部大获成功的法律。
It's like complaining about paying a lot of taxes. Like if you're paying a lot of taxes, things are going well. Amen. Yeah, so then why do you think that's not more universally embraced? Well, so I wrote an article in the New York Times. It was an op-ed. I was very proud of it, and you can go back and read it.
这就像抱怨交很多税一样。如果你交了很多税，说明事情进展得很顺利。说得好。对啊，那为什么你认为这种模式没有得到更普遍的接受呢？嗯，所以我曾在《纽约时报》上写过一篇文章。那是一篇专栏文章。我为此感到非常自豪，你们可以回去读一读。
Oh, I don't read. Tracy, no, Tracy can go back and read it. Tracy can read it to me. Or I'll read it to you, yeah. For New York Times. And it was all about the fact that I believe, if there's one, there are no rules to making movies and TV shows in my mind except one, which is if people have equity in what they're making
哦，我不看书。特雷西，不，特雷西可以回去读一读。特雷西可以读给我听。或者我读给你听，好啦。为了《纽约时报》。文章的核心就是，我认为——在我的观念里，制作电影和电视节目没有任何规则，除了唯一的一条，那就是如果人们对他们所制作的东西拥有股权，
as opposed to being paid upfront, what they're making is better. It just is. Absolutely, I totally agree. And that view has been very not, has been very out of fashion until the streaming correction, which happened about 18 months ago. But to put it in very broad terms,
而不是拿前期固定片酬，那么他们制作出来的东西就会更好。事实就是如此。绝对如此，我完全赞同。这种观点在流媒体大调整（大约发生在18个月前）之前一直非常不合时髦，非常冷门。但如果从宏观角度来讲，
starting in about 2010, there was an enormous amount of money. Wall Street gave not just Netflix, but all the streamers money, not based on their profit, but based on subscriber numbers. And the way to get subscriber numbers was to spend more and more and more and more. And so the industry as a whole spent more money than it was making because it wasn't using profit as a metric. Right. You with me? Yeah. 18 months ago when Netflix stock dropped,
大约从2010年开始，有海量的资金涌入。华尔街不仅给Netflix注资，还给所有的流媒体平台砸钱，看重的不是它们的利润，而是订阅用户的数量。而获取订阅用户数量的方法就是砸钱、砸钱、砸钱、再砸钱。因此，整个行业花的钱超过了它赚的钱，因为它没有把利润作为衡量标准。对吧。听懂了吗？对。18个月前，当Netflix的股价下跌时，
it's now back to beyond what it was before, which is going to tie into what I'm saying. But 18 months ago, when Netflix stock dropped, it's now back to beyond what it was before, but 18 months ago, Wall Street decided, that's dumb, streaming companies and media companies need to be like every other company, numbers or anything else or what you might eventually make in streaming, we're going to reward you for what actually makes money so that all the people who make content had to take a much closer look at their budgets. And the budgets are now all coming down a lot. And the quickest, most effective way to bring a budget down is to pay the people who make
现在它已经回升并超过了以前的水平，这与我要说的话有关。但18个月前，当Netflix的股价下跌时——虽然现在它已经回升并超越了从前，但在18个月前，华尔街决定：这太蠢了，流媒体公司和媒体公司必须像其他所有公司一样，不能只看数字或其他表象，也不管你在流媒体未来能赚多少钱，我们只会根据你实际产生利润的能力来回报你。因此，所有制作内容的人都不得不重新审视他们的预算。现在所有的预算都在大幅缩减。而削减预算最快、最有效的方法，就是付给那些制作内容的人——
the most money, which are the actors, the writers, the directors, and the producers, people who make the most money, much less unless the thing that they make makes money. And that's now... But the trick with streaming is that the ability to calculate what a profit is becomes vague, yes? Yes, but it's not it. That's such gobbledygook. It's the easiest thing in the world to create.
也就是拿钱最多的人，包括演员、编剧、导演和制片人——付给他们少得多的前期片酬，除非他们制作的东西能够真正赚钱。而现在……但流媒体的猫腻在于，计算什么是利润变得非常含糊，对吧？是的，但其实并非如此。那纯粹是一堆废话。那是世界上最简单不过的事情了。
They have the data of everything, you just have to decide. A penny a minute, a penny an hour, it doesn't, it's so. Whatever everybody universally decides on. It's way easier to make up a profit definition, yes. Here's the other thing that's interesting about it. I got carried away, go ahead. No, no, no, I think this is a great area,
他们掌握了所有数据的每一部分，你只需要做决定就行。每分钟一分钱，每小时一分钱，不管怎样，这太……无论大家共同决定采用什么标准。虚构一个利润定义其实要容易得多，对吧。还有一件事很有意思。我扯远了，你接着说。不，不，不，我觉得这是一个很棒的领域，
this is the other thing, cause it's, and I think that, I think that it's pretty cynical in the sense that the streamers, like you said, were given exorbitant amounts of cash to try to do that, to grow their business and to get subs. Well, it turns out that they figured out within that time, and this is probably five years ago, they realized when they started to offer things,
这也是另一个重点，因为它是……而且我认为，我认为这其实挺讽刺的，就像你说的，流媒体平台当初获得了大笔得离谱的现金来做这件事，为了扩大业务和获取订阅用户。结果证明，在那个时期内他们摸索出了门道——这大概是五年前的事了，他们开始提供某些内容时，
they started to offer ad customers, ad-supported customers, they realized that their ad-supported customer was worth more to them than a subscriber, that they would get more return on it. And so eventually, what the consumer doesn't understand that eventually we are gonna be going back to the old formula from before. Network television.
他们开始向广告客户、广告支持的用户提供内容时，他们意识到广告支持的用户对他们的价值比单纯的订阅用户更高，他们能从中获得更高的回报。所以最终，消费者并不明白，我们最终将回到以前的旧公式。电视网电视。
Yeah, so we're just coming to the tail end of this huge fucking cycle that was virtually meaningless. And now we're back to ad supported viewing is gonna be the thing that they are going after, et cetera. Am I right? Streaming is just basically an electrified VCR. That's all it is.
对，所以我们刚刚走到了这个该死的巨大周期的尾声，这个周期实际上毫无意义。现在我们又回到了以广告支持的观看模式将成为他们追逐的目标等等。我说的对吗？流媒体本质上不过是一台带电的录像机。仅此而已。
You can watch anything whenever you want, but otherwise it's going to be like it was before. I don't know if I totally agree with that, but it's changed a lot and it's changed not very much. I do agree with most of what you're saying. Yeah, because all the people that work at the streamers worked at the networks. Well, that's true.
你随时随地都可以看任何东西，但除此之外，它将和以前一模一样。我不知道我是不是完全同意这种说法，但它的确发生了很大变化，同时又好像没变多少。你说的绝大部分我确实是赞同的。对，因为所有在流媒体工作的人以前都在电视网工作过。嗯，这倒也是。
They're almost all the same people. That's true. That culture has shifted and all that stuff that they said that separated them and made them different at all the streamers now does not separate them or make them different and it's very, very difficult. Well, but hang on.
他们几乎全都是同一批人。确实如此。这种文化已经发生了转变，所有那些他们曾经标榜用来将自己与众不同、在各个流媒体平台脱颖而出的说辞，现在已经无法将他们区分开来，也无法让他们变得与众不同，这真的、真的很困难。不过，等一下。
I mean, we're talking about something that for the most part is subscriber supported. The ad supported viewer is a small fraction of that. And they want it to be bigger. Not as a part of the general population because people still watch a lot of network TV, but for streaming, ad supportedsupported streaming is a smaller piece than subscription for streaming.
我的意思是，我们讨论的大部分内容仍然是靠订阅支撑的。看带广告的观众只占其中很小的一部分。而且他们希望这个比例能更大。这并不是指在总人口中的比例，因为人们仍然看很多电视网的电视节目，但就流媒体而言，带广告的流媒体所占的份额比订阅流媒体要小。
Yeah, and it's still hard to argue with, you know, having 250 million people spending $15 a month is a pretty yummy business if you can retain those people month after month after month after month, and it really is, it's a retention business. It's not an ad selling business. Did you know? Well, it'll be both.
对，而且依然很难反驳这种观点：拥有250万（应为2.5亿）人每人每月花15美元，如果你能让他们月复一月、年复一年地留存下来，这绝对是一笔相当诱人的生意。它确实是一个靠用户留存的业务。而不是一个靠卖广告的业务。你知道吗？好吧，两者兼而有之。
You'll have, and by the way, movies are different in a different category than what you guys are talking about, studios, it's different, but there will be a bunch of people, a bunch of subscribers paying a premium for no ads, and then there'll be a bunch of people watching programming with ads for either less or no money. JB, I don't disagree with you.
你会有，顺便说一句，电影和你们讨论的类别不同，电影公司情况不一样，但会有一群人、一大批订阅用户支付高额费用来免除广告，然后也会有一批人观看带有广告的节目，只需付较少的钱甚至不花钱。JB，我并不是在反驳你。
What I'm saying is that that is what they have decided that they want to move towards because it is more profitable. And I guarantee you, all of them are going to tend towards the thing that is more profitable. It's what they want. If it was more profitable, then why wouldn't linear television be in better health? Well, there are, because there are things
我想说的是，这正是他们决定想要发展方向，因为这样更有利可图。我向你保证，他们所有人都会倾向于那个更有利可图的方向。这就是他们的目标。如果那样更有利可图，那为什么传统线性电视的状况没有更好呢？嗯，有一些原因，因为有些事情
that are showing up to be, that are proving that, which are things like 2B and all these sort of fast channel type things. These are proving to be really effective ways that people are watching stuff who don't wanna have to pay the subscriber a monthly fee and who are willing to watch ads. And that kind of stuff, that stuff is growing.
正在显现出来，并被证明是行之有效的，比如2B（Tubi）以及所有这些所谓的快速频道（FAST channel）之类的东西。事实证明，对于那些不想支付每月订阅费、愿意看广告的人来说，这些是非常有效的观看途径。诸如此类的事物，它们正在不断增长。
It's all about what's available. Wait, what is Tubi? Do I have Tubi? That's a long callback. That is a, that's like a three year callback. Jason Blum, I want to talk about your stuff, because I'm a fan. And so first of all, I wanted to-
这全都是关于有什么可看的。等等，什么是Tubi？我有Tubi吗？这是一个很长的梗。那是一个，那就像一个三年前的梗。杰森·布伦，我想聊聊你的作品，因为我是你的粉丝。所以首先，我想——
Okay, well then start. You're a guest today. So paranormal- He's got 17 million questions for you. I do, I do. Paranormal Activity is one of my favorite movies. I watched it a year ago with my nieces. Yep, quote it.
好吧，那就开始吧。你今天可是嘉宾。所以灵异——他有一千七百万个问题要问你。我确实有，我确实有。《灵异妙探》（应为《灵异实录》）是我最喜欢的电影之一。我一年前还和我的侄女们一起看过。是的，引用一下它的台词吧。
Well, just, I could talk about it all day long. Then start. Okay. Keep saying it. You're like a rapper could talk about it all day long. Then start. Okay. Keep saying, you're like a rapper who goes, I'm going to rock the microphone, wait till I get on the mic. And you're like, okay, you've got the microphone. Fucking do it. The fuck? I'm going to rock the mic.
好吧，就，我可以一整天都在聊它。那就开始吧。行。继续说。你就像个说唱歌手，一整天都在吹嘘。那就开始吧。好吧。继续说，你就像那种说唱歌手，总是说“我要震撼麦克风，等我上台拿麦”，然后你就像在说：好吧，麦克风给你了。赶紧给老子唱啊。搞什么鬼？我要震撼麦克风。
And when I get on the microphone, I'm really going to, then fucking do it. That's how I felt about this mystery product coming in. Yeah, I know that's true. That's true, fair enough, fair enough. Oh, I'm, oh, by the way, I'm a hypocrite in my core. Well, but Jason, tell me about it, because wasn't it true that the studio wanted you to remake it, or they didn't like it,
说什么“当我拿到麦克风时，我真的会……”那就给老子唱啊！我当时对这个神秘产品的到来就是这种感觉。对，我知道这是真的。没错，这倒也是，合情合理，合情合理。哦，我是，哦，顺便说一句，我骨子里就是个伪君子。好吧，但杰森，跟我讲讲吧，难道不是真的吗：电影公司当时想让你翻拍它，或者他们不喜欢它，
or whatever, and how did you convince them that they had gold and all that kind of stuff? Tell me about this one. Paranormal Activity, I'll do the quicker version of it. Yeah, yeah, yeah, that was what launched the company. But I had a guy, this very sweet fellow who I'm still friends with and a very good producer, a guy named Steven Schneider, and he was a horror expert.
诸如此类，你是怎么说服他们手里握着摇钱树的，以及诸如此类的事情？跟我讲讲这个吧。《灵异实录》，我长话短说吧。对，对，对，就是那部片子启动了这家公司。但我当时有个合作伙伴，一个非常可爱的小伙子，我们现在还是朋友，也是个非常优秀的制片人，名叫史蒂芬·施耐德，他是个恐怖片专家。
I had a deal at Paramount and he had a deal with us and we had a deal with them. And Paramount, you know, whatever, was ignoring me. And this guy, Steven, showed me this movie, showed me Paranormal Activity and I saw it like, you know, on a DVD at my house. And it'd been at a couple festivals and whatever. And...
我当时在派拉蒙签有合约，而他和我们签有合约，我们和他们也有合约。派拉蒙呢，你懂的，一直在无视我。然后这个叫史蒂芬的家伙，把这部电影拿给我看，让我看了《灵异实录》，我是通过我家里的DVD看的。它之前在几个电影节上放映过，诸如此类。然后……
You were living in New York at the time? I was, no, I was living on Sunset Plaza, in my bachelor pad on Sunset Plaza, before I moved downtown. And... And... Exactly. And...
你当时住在纽约吗？我当时，不，我住在日落广场，我在日落广场的单身公寓里，在我搬到市中心之前。然后……然后……正是如此。然后……
And I had passed on Blair Witch Project, like... I can't believe that. And now you're remaking it. Yes. We're trying. We're trying. We'll see. Yeah, we're trying.
然后我错过了《布莱尔女巫项目》，就像……我简直不敢相信。而现在你正在翻拍它。是的。我们在尝试。我们在尝试。走着瞧吧。对，我们在尝试。
I know. Crazy. No. But yeah, I passed on it, and I was never like, my boss just was like, you idiot for a year, you know? A year, I had to listen to that. But when I saw Paranormal, I had this like, oh my God, what if this is Blair Witch? And I didn't say like, this movie's gonna be,
我知道。太疯狂了。不。但确实，我错过了它，我从来没有——我的老板整整一年都在说“你这个白痴”，你知道吗？一整年，我都得听这些唠叨。但当我看到《灵异实录》时，我心里闪过一个念头：天哪，万一这就是《布莱尔女巫》呢？我并不是说这部电影会……
I didn't think the movie's gonna be anything of what it turned out to be, but I definitely thought there was something to it, and I thought it was worth screening it in front of an audience. That's what I learned from Blair Witch, is if you see anything somewhat that might be good, throw it in front of an audience.
我当时并不认为这部电影会变成后来的那种大爆款，但我绝对觉得它有点名堂，我觉得值得把它放在观众面前放映测试一下。这就是我从《布莱尔女巫》身上学到的：如果你看到任何可能还不错的苗头，就把它扔到观众面前去测试。
Yes, because we love testing. I love testing. So anyway. The smile on his face when you said that. No, but it's true, I've heard you talk about that. Testing is my dream, yeah. I don't like friends and family testing. I like testing with real, objective people.
对，因为我们热爱测试。我热爱测试。所以总之。当你这么说时，他脸上的笑容。不，但这是真的，我听你谈起过这个。测试是我的梦想，是的。我不喜欢“朋友和家人”式的测试。我喜欢用真实的、客观的人来做测试。
Testing the film in front of a random audience. Regular audience. And then they all fill out what they like, what they didn't like, and you get a number. I'm not such a big fan of that, but I like watching the movie with a regular crowd. Got it. Yeah, it's the best feedback ever, yeah.
把电影放在随机挑选的观众面前进行测试。普通观众。然后他们都会填写他们喜欢什么，不喜欢什么，你就会得到一个分数。我其实不太喜欢那样，但我喜欢和普通观众一起看电影。明白了。对，这是史上最棒的反馈，真的。
Yeah, yeah, yeah. So anyway, I have this itch I want to scratch on this movie and I met the director and he had basically sold it to a, he sold it for 100 grand to direct a DVD, to IFC, by the way, who never forget, a guy named Jonathan Searing was there at the time, he never forgave me for this. Because I said, it's a deal done,
对，对，对。所以总之，我有一块心病想在这部电影上解决，我见到了导演，他基本上把它卖给了一个——他以10万美元的价格把导演DVD版权卖给了IFC，顺便说一句，永远不要忘记，当时有个叫乔纳森·西林的家伙在那里，他至今都没原谅我。因为我说，这是一个已经谈妥的交易，
he said, no, it's not done, but I think I'm going to just sell it for 100. Because I said, it's a deal done. He said, no, it's not done, but I think I'm going to just sell it for 100 grand. I said, I think the movie should be in theaters. I told him the Blair Witch story. I said, give me a cut of whatever you make after you make $500,000. So I'm not going to cost you anything unless I make five times the money you've already made.
他说，不，还没谈妥，但我想要不就10万块卖了吧。因为我说这已经是一笔谈妥的买卖了。他说，不，还没谈妥，但我可能就以10万块把它卖了。我说，我觉得这部电影应该上院线。我把《布莱尔女巫》的故事讲给他听。我说，给我你在赚到50万美元之后赚到的所有钱的分成。所以我不会让你花一分钱，除非我赚到你已经赚到的钱的五倍。
Then I want a piece, but until then, nothing. And let me come on and partner, see if I can get it made with you. Anyway, three years goes by, no one wants the movie. I do the movie with the audience like I want to do. It's very clear if you see the movie with an audience, it's going to be a crazy hit, it's very clear. But I'm the, you know, schmuck producer.
然后我才要分红，但在那之前，什么都没有。让我加入并成为合伙人，看看我能不能帮你把它拍出来。总之，三年过去了，没有人想要这部电影。我按照我的想法带着观众一起做了这部电影。很明显，如果你和观众一起看这部电影，它绝对会成为一部超级大热门，非常明显。但我只是个，你知道的，无名小卒制片人。
I call everyone and say, you got to watch this movie with an audience. They say, well, we've already seen it. We have got the DVD here. It's sitting on my assistant's desk and the movie sucks. And, and... That's so good. That's the way a lot of conversations go in Hollywood. Yeah, exactly.
我给所有人打电话说，你们得和观众一起看这部电影。他们说，噢，我们已经看过了。DVD就在这儿呢。正搁在我助理的桌子上呢，这电影烂透了。然后，然后……太搞笑了。好莱坞的大多数谈话都是这样进行的。对，完全如此。
Wow. We'll be right back. All right, back to the show. So three years into this, I get Paramount won't return my calls and it still drives me crazy that the movie wound up with them because they hated the movie forever. But I get DreamWorks, this guy Adam Goodman. I know Adam.
哇。我们马上回来。好了，回到节目中来。所以三年过去了，我发现派拉蒙根本不回我的电话，这部电影最后竟然落在了他们手里，这至今仍让我抓狂，因为他们永远都讨厌这部电影。但我找到了梦工厂，一个叫亚当·古德曼的家伙。我认识亚当。
You know Adam, you remember Adam, right? Yeah, of course, great guy, made a couple movies with him. Yeah, Adam and Ashley Brooks, and they're working at DreamWorks, and they're really into the movie, I give them credit for that, and they said, well, we're going to remake the movie, you know, we'll put famous people in the movie.
你认识亚当，你记得亚当对吧？对，当然，人很好，跟他合作过几部电影。对，亚当和阿什利·布鲁克斯，他们在梦工厂工作，他们真的很喜欢这部电影，我得为这一点给他们点赞，他们说，好吧，我们要翻拍这部电影，你知道的，我们会在电影里加入大明星。
Movies have found footage movies, so I don't know how it could work with famous people, but I say, this is my flash of brilliance, of which I've had two in my career, but this was one of them. And I said, I will, first of all, you gotta pay me 150 grand, because I need more than 100 for Oran,
电影是伪纪录片风格的，所以我不知道怎么能用大明星来拍，但我说——这是我灵光一闪的时刻，在我的职业生涯中有过两次，而这是其中一次。我说：首先，你们得付给我15万美元，因为我得给奥伦（导演）超过10万块，
so I gotta get him an extra 50 grand. Second, you gotta put the original movie on the DVD. When we remake the new movie, you gotta put the original movie on that DVD, because I want it out there somewhere. Oh, wow. Third, you have to test the original parent-owned activity. You have to test screen the film in Burbank
所以我得给他额外5万美元。第二，你们必须把原版电影收录在DVD里。当我们翻拍新电影时，你们必须把原版电影也放在那个DVD里，因为我想让它在某个地方公之于众。哦，哇。第三，你们必须对原版的《灵异实录》进行试映测试。你们必须在伯班克进行试映，
with 300 people and you, Adam, and it was Stacey Snyder, his boss, and Stacey Snyder, you guys have to be there. And not because I want to release the movie because if I said that, they would have said, you're an idiot. I said because when we remake the movie, I want to release the movie, because if I said that, they would have said, you're an idiot. I said, because when we remake the movie, I want to invite the writers
找300个人，你，亚当——当时还有斯黛西·施耐德，他的老板，斯黛西·施耐德，你们大家必须都在场。不是因为我想发行这部电影——如果我这么说了，他们会觉得我是个白痴。我说的是，当我们翻拍这部电影时，我想发行这部电影——如果我这么说了，他们会觉得我是个白痴。我说，是因为当我们翻拍电影时，我想邀请那些
who are going to write the remake, and I want all you executives to be there with the writers so we can decide which parts we're going to redo and which parts we're going to leave, right? I love that, I love that. And then I said to the director, Oren, who I give Oren so much credit for sticking with me all this time,
将要编写翻拍剧本的编剧们，而且我希望你们所有高管都和编剧们一起在场，这样我们就能决定哪些部分我们要重拍，哪些部分我们要保留，对吧？我喜欢这个，我太喜欢这个了。然后我对导演奥伦说——我对奥伦真的充满感激，他这么长时间以来一直坚定地支持我，
three years into this, he had 150 grand three years ago, he's still, he's sleeping in my guest house for half the time, he was in San Diego, but he used to sleep in my guest house all the time for all these dumb meetings we would have where people would say the movies doesn't work. And I said to Oren, Oren, I will bet you a nickel that if Adam and Stacey
三年过去了，他三年前拿到了15万块，他现在依然……有一半时间睡在我的客房里，他虽然住在圣迭戈，但他以前经常睡在我的客房里，为了我们那些愚蠢的会议，在会上人们总说这部电影行不通。我对奥伦说：奥伦，我跟你赌一个镍币，如果亚当和斯黛西
watch this movie with a recruited audience, which was impossible to do, if they watch this movie with a recruited audience, they're never going to talk about the remake again. Just trust me. And by the way, worst case scenario, if they do, you're going to get a buck 50 instead of a hundred, so it's no loose.
带着一组招募来的观众来看这部电影——当时这几乎是不可能的任务，如果他们带着招募来的观众看这部电影，他们就再也不会提翻拍的事了。相信我。顺便说一句，最坏的情况是，如果他们真的提了，你也能拿到15万而不是10万，所以你稳赚不赔。
And I still remember, Warren, Steven, and I went to this screening, it was in Burbank, and Stacey was there, and fucking people went insane. And three people left the theater because they were too scared. And the movie ends and everyone goes nuts, and Stacey, I will never forget, Stacey Snyder is at the bottom of the,
我依然记得，奥伦、史蒂芬和我去了那场试映会，地点在伯班克，斯黛西也在场，结果现场观众简直疯狂了。有三个人因为太害怕而中途退场了。电影放完后全场炸锅了，斯黛西——我永远不会忘记，斯黛西·施耐德站在……的底部，
and she's literally, the writers were there for the remake, they disappear, and Stacey has the three of us pitching us the 30 second TV spots of how she's going to sell the movie. The theatrical release. Wow. The movie as is. As is. The remake's off the table, and then Spielberg gets
她简直……翻拍电影的编剧们当时也在场，结果他们人不见了，斯黛西把我们三个人拉过去，向我们推销她打算如何把这部电影卖出去的30秒电视广告创意。院线公映。哇。就按原样上映。原汁原味。翻拍计划泡汤了，然后斯皮尔伯格拿到了
the results of the test, he sees it like two days later. He loves it. And DreamWorks is releasing our movie. And then, and another thing, I won't go into it now, but DreamWorks then and Paramount split up. And DreamWorks went to Disney. And Disney, DreamWorks could not have their first release be Paranormal Activity.
测试结果，他在两天后看到了。他爱死这部电影了。梦工厂要发行我们的电影了。然后，还有一件事，我现在不细说，但梦工厂后来和派拉蒙分家了。梦工厂去了迪士尼。而迪士尼，梦工厂绝不能让他们的第一部发行作品是《灵异实录》。
So we were saddled with Paramount and another year of shenanigans, which is how it wound up with them. No way, another year from that moment? It was a year, they said they weren't going to release it. They blackmailed us, they blackmailed us into releasing them, I've never really been this straightforward about it, but I will be now.
所以我们被塞给了派拉蒙，又经历了一年的尔虞我诈，这就是为什么它最后落在了派拉蒙手里。开什么玩笑，从那个时刻算起又过了一年？确实是一年，他们说他们不打算发行这部电影。他们勒索我们，他们勒索我们让他们发行，我以前从来没有这么直白地谈过这件事，但现在我要说了。
We had, based off that test screening, we were able to sell five million bucks of international sales. So based off the fact that it was gonna get a domestic release by a studio, we had five million dollars in sales. All the France and Germany, we sold territory by territory, right?
当时根据那场试映会的效果，我们成功卖出了500万美元的海外发行权。所以基于这部电影将由一家大公司进行本土发行的事实，我们获得了500万美元的销售额。所有法国和德国的版权，我们按地区一个接一个地卖出去了，对吧？
You're already in profit. We had, oh my God, in profit, but the movie cost 15 grand. So we had 18 months to get the release, which by the way, no problem. Stacey and Steven Spielberg loved the movie. Dreamworks is releasing the movie, boom. Disney were at Paramount. Paramount's like, we're not releasing the movie.
你们已经盈利了。我们已经，天哪，大赚特赚了，但这部电影只花了一万五千美元。所以我们有18个月的时间来搞定发行，顺便说一句，这完全没问题。斯黛西和史蒂芬·施耐德都爱惨了这部电影。梦工厂要发行这部电影了，太棒了。迪士尼把我们甩给了派拉蒙。派拉蒙的态度是：我们不打算发行这部电影。
Wow. And it went on and they- Why were they opposed to releasing it? They thought it was a piece of shit, like everybody else. Wow. But what about this? The only savior was that when Disney and DreamWorks broke up, Adam Goodman and Ashley Brooks moved-
哇。事情就这么拖着，他们——他们为什么反对发行？他们觉得这片子就是一堆狗屎，跟其他人想的一样。哇。但这个呢？唯一的救星是，当迪士尼和梦工厂分道扬镳时，亚当·古德曼和阿什利·布鲁克斯跳槽到了——
Went to Paramount. From DreamWorks to Paramount. So internally, they were doing what I was doing on the outside. So on the outside, I was... And internally, they were saying, guys, you got to... But everyone was saying to them, you guys are insane, don't do this movie. And basically, what happened, in retrospect,
去了派拉蒙。从梦工厂跳槽到了派拉蒙。所以他们在内部做着我一直在外部做的事。在外部，我一直在……而在内部，他们一直在说：伙计们，你们必须……但所有人都在对他们说：你们疯了吗，千万别接这部电影。基本上，后来发生的事，事后回想起来，
history is rewritten like they did this strategic smart release. No. Adam and Ashley got them to agree to pay a million bucks in P&A to do this tiny release of the movie. Print and advertise. a strategic smart release. and we'll put 500 up and we'll put it in 13 theaters. Demand it, which was only, that was, the whole marketing thing was just like, how can we spend as little money as possible to get this movie out there? I mean, isn't it amazing you have that? Wow! That's actually,
历史被重新书写得好像他们进行了一次明智的战略发行一样。根本不是。亚当和阿什利说服他们同意支付100万美元的P&A（宣传发行费）来对这部电影进行极小规模的发行。印制胶片和广告。一次明智的战略发行。我们出50万，把它放到13家影院上映。要求这么做，这其实，整个营销策略仅仅是：我们怎么能花最少量的钱把这电影搞上映呢？我的意思是，你不觉得拥有这样的经历很神奇吗？哇！这其实是，
I've never really, really told that part of the story, but it's a great thing. It's amazing. But isn't it amazing that you have this thing and what it takes to get people to believe in it and you just didn't stop, and isn't it fascinating that you have this thing and what it takes to get people to believe in it and you just didn't stop. And isn't it fascinating that you can see it, but the people in charge can never see it? Why is that?
我以前从来没有真正、真正讲过故事的这一部分，但真的很棒。太神奇了。但你不觉得拥有这样一个项目，以及为了让人们相信它所付出的努力——你始终没有放弃，这太神奇了吗？你不觉得你能看到它的价值，但掌权的人却永远看不到，这很不可思议吗？为什么会这样？
Well, no, it's, you know, those stories though, I mean, you guys know these stories too. It's, I have a little, like, it's always annoying, the story, there's so many stories of I believed in it and nobody didn't. Right, sure. And it's, it favors the producer so much, because executives, their job is to look at 400 things
嗯，不，你知道，不过那些故事，我的意思是，你们也知道这些故事。总是有点，怎么说呢，挺烦人的，有那么多“我坚信它而别人不信”的故事。对，当然。而且这对制片人太有利了，因为高管们的工作是看400个项目
and pick 10. So they have to not believe in 390 things. So it's not really fair. Producer's job is to pick 20 things, believe in all of them, and 10 go, you know, whatever it is. So I always think those stories are kind of dopey, including this story. Like, I don't...
然后挑出10个。所以他们必须拒绝390个项目。这其实不太公平。制片人的工作是挑选20个项目，坚定不移地相信它们中的每一个，然后其中10个成功了，你知道，诸如此类。所以我一直觉得这类故事有点蠢，包括这个故事在内。我不觉得……
It's fascinating though. It's... No, I don't, it's fascinating except it's not like, I give myself credit for that one thing of, of, you know, putting that language in the test screening, but anyone, any of you or anyone, if you saw the movie with an audience before it came out, you would know it was a hit.
不过这确实很迷人。这……不，我不觉得，这很迷人，只不过……我只把功劳归于我自己做的那一小件事，也就是在试映调查中加入了那种排片机制，但任何人，你们中的任何人，如果在电影上映前跟观众一起看过这部电影，你就会知道它绝对会大爆。
It's just I couldn't get anyone into the theater. Right, right, right. There was no genius of knowing that. But you did, and it still took all of that work to get it a wide release. Well, I had no clout. I had no clout. It's like this little, this guy with? Well, I had no clout. I had no clout. You know, it's like this little, you know, this
只是我当时谁也拉不进影院里而已。对，对，对。这根本不需要什么天才般的洞察力。但你确实做到了，而且为了让它大规模上映，你付出了全部的心血。好吧，我当时没有任何势力。我毫无势力。就像这个小小的，这个家伙带着——好吧，我毫无势力。我毫无势力。你知道，就像这个小小的，你知道的，这个
guy with no, like I had no track record. I produced six independent movies. They were all terrible. One was okay and five were horrible. So it was like, why am I going to, why am I going to waste my night and be away from my kids by this schmuck, when everyone in my team has seen the movie and they think it's not good, which by the way, which I get too. How under the hood do you like to get creatively as far as script notes and edit notes and all that? I hate being on set.
一无所有的人，我当时毫无业绩可言。我制作过六部独立电影。它们全都很烂。一部还凑合，五部烂透了。所以大家会想：我为什么要浪费我的夜晚，离开我的孩子，去陪这个无名小卒呢？既然我团队里的每个人都看过这部电影，并且觉得它不好——顺便说一句，这种心态我也能理解。在发挥创意方面，比如剧本意见、剪辑意见这些，你喜欢深入到什么程度？我讨厌去片场。
I like running my production company. I give usually a couple of notes on a script, a few notes on a cut, depending on the cut. Sometimes I give more notes on the finished movie than the script, but Cooper Samuelson, who you know well, he's the, he's the, The great Cooper Samuelson. He's the great, we've been together 10 years,
我喜欢运营我的制作公司。我对剧本通常会提一两条意见，对剪辑版提几条意见，具体要看剪辑的完成度。有时我对完成的电影提的意见比对剧本还多，但库珀·萨缪尔森——你们很熟，他是那个——伟大的库珀·萨缪尔森。他是那个伟大的，我们已经合作10年了，
and he really runs the movie, no, he does run the movie company, and he is very, he and his team are extremely involved. What would you say is your fastball then? Like identifying a filmmaker, a concept, a script, where do you think your greatest talent lies if it's not getting in there under the hood day to day, quality control, et cetera, et cetera?
他 realmente 负责电影，不，他确实负责电影公司，而且他和他的团队极其投入。那依你来看，你的“直球”（核心优势）是什么？比如识别一个电影人、一个概念、一个剧本，如果你不经常深入一线去把控日常的质量控制等等，你觉得你最大的天赋在哪里？
Well, I'm a great picker, I'm a good picker. I'm a very good picker, I am a good picker. So that is quality control. And I'm a good seller. And I'm not talking about, it's easy to raise money for the movies now, but I'm good at talking people into working for me, working for us. I'm good at it.
嗯，我很擅长挑选，我是一个优秀的选片人。我是一个非常优秀的选片人，我确实很擅长选片。所以这就是质量控制。而且我很擅长推销。我说的不是——现在给电影筹集资金很容易，但我很擅长说服别人为我工作、为我们工作。我很擅长这个。
But it's an easy thing for me, it's an easy thing to sell because I believe it. I really believe in our model and I believe in the company and I believe the model leads to better movies and shows. The only thing that I was going to say is there's really no other companies that just do one thing. And that's been a huge advantage to us. And now, the second, the only other company that really does just do one thing like we do at scale is James Wan's Atomic Monster.
但对我来说这是一件轻而易举的事，推销起来很简单，因为我坚信不疑。我真的很相信我们的模式，我相信这家公司，我也相信这种模式能带来更好的电影和节目。我本来想说的是，真的没有其他公司只专注于做一件事。这给我们带来了巨大的优势。而现在，第二家、也是唯一一家真正像我们一样大规模只做一件事的公司，是温子仁的原子怪兽公司（Atomic Monster）。
And now Atomic Monster and Blumhouse, we put the companies together 16 months ago. And it's a huge advantage to not do horror as like a side hustle. You know, which that's what the studios do obviously, but also most production company, most other production companies, they do all the thing and we do the occasional horror movie. And that's all we do.
现在“原子怪兽”和布伦屋（Blumhouse）合并了，我们在16个月前把这两家公司合二为一了。不把恐怖片当成兼职副业，这有着巨大的优势。你知道的，这显然是电影公司会做的事，而且大多数制作公司、绝大多数其他制作公司，他们什么类型都拍，而我们只是偶尔拍拍恐怖片。这就是我们做的全部。
I see every horror movie. That's- Well, Blum, that's, of course you're occasional horror movie and that's all we do. I see every horror movie That's of course you're good at because that is what you do your specialty you understand it Now you have you're doing it with James Wan talk a little bit about your your relationship with James Wan and and how that came to be well I'm interested in growing the company and I really felt like this kind of this is actually kind of It kind of ties together a lot of the stuff that we've been talking about.
我看每一部恐怖片。那是——好吧，布伦，那是，你当然擅长偶尔拍拍恐怖片，因为这就是你们的全部工作，是你们的专业，你们懂这个。现在你和温子仁一起合作，稍微聊聊你和温子仁的关系以及它是如何促成的吧？嗯，我有兴趣壮大公司，我真的觉得这其实有点——这其实把我们刚才讨论的很多事情都串联起来了。
It's that I don't believe you can make, let's just talk about movies and not TV for a second. I don't believe you can make movies, you can make more movies that are good by just hiring more people, right? And remember, we only get paid if our movies are good or if they work. If they don't work, we don't get paid.
那就是我不认为你可以通过仅仅雇佣更多的人来制作更多的好电影，我们只谈电影先不说电视，对吧？记住，只有当我们的电影拍得好或者卖座时，我们才能拿到报酬。如果它们不卖座，我们就一分钱也拿不到。
So for us to go from four or five movies a year to seven or eight movies a year, we have to keep the quality the same. If the quality goes down, it's a disaster. So the only way for us to grow is to go from four or five to six or seven. And it was my view that the only way to get to six or seven. And it was my view that the only way to get to six or seven was to bring in a partner,
所以对我们来说，要从一年拍四五部电影发展到一年拍七八部，我们必须保持质量不变。如果质量下降，那就是一场灾难。因此，我们发展的唯一途径就是从四五部增加到六七部。我的观点是，要做到六七部的唯一途径是引入一个合作伙伴，
not just to hire four more executives, but to bring in a partner who was a visionary who was doing this on his own. And if you take Blumhouse and Atomic Monster and if those two companies just continue to do what the an atomic monster and if those two companies just continue to do what the companies have done on their own the last 10 years, it's like 60% of theatrically released horror movies have been done by those two companies. Yeah, talking about James Wan, some of the things that he's done.
不只是多雇四个高管，而是引入一个本身就在独立做这件事的远见卓识的合作伙伴。如果你把布伦屋和原子怪兽结合起来，如果这两家公司只是继续做这两家公司过去10年里各自一直在做的事情，那么全美院线上映的恐怖片里大约有60%都是这两家公司制作的。对，说到温子仁，他做过的一些事情。
So James Wan, first of all, he's a massive director, separate business, Aquaman, Fast and Furious, right, but he birthed Insidious with us, which is how I met him. But Atomic Monster is best known as the production company behind The Conjuring Universe. So all the Conjuring movies, Annabelle, La Llorona. Huge. Huge.
所以温子仁，首先，他是一位大导演，那是另一块业务，《海王》、《速度与激情》，对吧，但他和我们一起孕育了《潜伏》，这就是我认识他的原因。但原子怪兽最著名的身份是“招魂宇宙”背后的制作公司。所以所有的《招魂》电影、安娜贝尔、《哭泣女人的诅咒》都是他们出品的。大热。大热。
It's a, yeah, The Nun, The Nun 2. Nun 2, no one ever talks about it, but Nun 2 was the second highest grossing horror movie of all time last year. No one? Wow! $270 million, the Nun 2. No one talks about it in Hollywood. So anyway, so next year, 25 is our first year
这是一个，对，《修女》、《修女2》。《修女2》，虽然没人谈论它，但《修女2》是去年有史以来全球票房第二高的恐怖片。没人谈？哇！2.7亿美元，《修女2》。好莱坞根本没人提它。所以总之，明年，25年将是我们第一年，
where our release date slate will be, we're up to our eight movies. We have Wolfman, we have two original movies, we have a Chris Landon movie called Drop, and then we have Megan, then we have Black Phone, then we have Five Nights at Freddy's 2, and then these guys have a Mortal Kombat movie and a Conjuring 5 movie.
我们的上映片单将达到八部电影。我们有《狼人》，我们有两部原创电影，一部是克里斯·兰登执导的电影叫《Drop》，然后我们有《梅根》，然后我们有《黑色电话》，然后我们有《玩具熊的五夜后宫2》，然后这几位还有一部《真人快打》电影和一部《招魂5》电影。
So next year is our big year. What percentage of box office does horror make up now, domestically? It's like a billion dollars a year. Billion dollars a year. Which is what percentage? It's about eight, nine, right about 10%. Good Lord.
所以明年将是我们的超级大年。恐怖片目前在北美本土票房中占多大比例？大约是一年十亿美元。一年十亿美元。那占多大比例？大概是百分之八、九，差不多百分之十。天哪。
So every award show where we're lauding all these other people, they should do, the first five minutes should just be a standing O for you and Juan, just to say thank you for keeping us all at work and now let's get to the Oscars. Five minutes standing O, Blum. Right, and they are, starting a long time ago, they've got really cinematic and less sort of like, you know, the rap they used to get with Slasher and Exploitative and whatnot. They're like beautifully made films now.
所以每一个把掌声送给其他所有人的颁奖典礼上，前五分钟都应该全体起立向你和温子仁致敬，仅仅是为了感谢你们让我们所有人都有班可上，现在让我们进入奥斯卡颁奖环节吧。全体起立鼓掌五分钟，布伦。没错，而且它们——很久以前就开始了，它们变得越来越有电影感，不再像以前那样背负着砍杀片、剥削片之类的恶名了。它们现在是制作精美的电影了。
Yeah, there's less TNA, I will say that. I'm sorry, not to knock it. Sorry about that. Now, do you know, I heard, maybe someone has talked to you about this on the show, but do you know, I heard that kids don't want TNA in movies now because there's so much of it on the internet that they don't want TNA in movies anymore.
行吧，现在的TNA（性感女郎）确实变少了，我得这么说。抱歉，我不是在贬低它。真是不好意思。话说你知道吗，我听说，也许有人在节目里跟你聊过这个，但我听说，现在孩子们看电影时不想看到TNA了，因为互联网上这类的东西太多了，所以他们不再希望电影里有TNA。
Wow, no kidding. Makes sense. Yeah, real progress. Yeah, and they don't want TNA in movies anymore. Wow, no kidding. I'm not kidding. Yeah, real progress. Yeah, and they don't want their driver's license either because there's Uber, you know. If you can get it somewhere else, I don't want it here. Jason Blum, I'm a big fan of Get Out and we don't have time to go through it
哇，真的假的？有道理。对啊，真正的进步。对啊，他们再也不想在电影里看到TNA了。哇，真的假的？我没开玩笑。对啊，真正的进步。对啊，他们甚至连驾照都不想要了，因为现在有Uber，你知道的。如果你在别的地方能弄到，我就不在这儿要了。杰森·布伦，我是《逃出绝命镇》的超级粉丝，虽然我们没时间深入聊这个
because we're going to let you go, but I didn't know there was. Oh my God, you're already over time. Jason, you're very, I didn't even know. This might be the quickest we've ever gotten to it and feel like we're just starting. Yeah, we really are. I got so much more to go into. God, I thought you were going to be a disappointing guest. I know, but in four years.
因为我们要放你走了，但我不知道原来有……天哪，你已经超时了。杰森，你真是……我甚至都不知道。这可能是我们最快进入主题的一次，感觉我们才刚开始。对啊，确实如此。我还有好多想深入聊的内容呢。天哪，我还以为你会是个让人失望的嘉宾呢。我知道，但这四年里……
Bateman kept saying, I'm not going to respond to this guy's emails. Don't respond to him. Can't make a deal. No, I can imagine before the show, I said, did Blum email you the other week? Oh my goodness, this guy won't stop. Who's going to break first, then Sean? Oh my gosh, Sean broke first. Wait, Sean had a question though, do ask it.
贝特曼一直说：“我才不回这家伙的邮件呢。别回他。根本没法谈合作。”不，我可以想象，在节目开始前我说：“布伦上周给你发邮件了吗？”哦天哪，这家伙没完没了了。那到底谁先妥协呢，肖恩？哦天哪，肖恩先妥协了。等等，肖恩倒是有个问题，快问吧。
Call her? No, well, it's too long to get into and I can probably just Google it, but I did not know there was a different ending to Get Out. There was, that was a note I had, that was a note I had. There was an end date to get out where Daniel died. And, or Daniel wound up in jail. Wound up in jail.
叫她？不，好吧，这话说来话长，我可能直接Google一下就行了，但我之前真不知道《逃出绝命镇》还有一个不同的结局。确实有，那是我的一个意见，那是我的一个意见。《逃出绝命镇》原本有一个结局是丹尼尔死了。而且，或者丹尼尔最后进了监狱。最后进了监狱。
Something terrible. Did they write it? Did they shoot it? Yeah, we shot it. It was at the test screening. And we tested it. And me and my very like, you know, not thoughtful self, I come bounding down the aisle
发生了很可怕的事。他们写出来了吗？拍出来了吗？对，我们拍了。那是试映的时候。我们进行了测试。而我和我那种非常……你知道的，不太会考虑那么多的性格，我一路冲过走道
and I'm like, Jordan, the movie's great. You cannot leave this end. I'm like, I didn't hedge, I didn't want to, you have to change the end. I said, Daniel is too good, everyone is in love with him, the movie's amazing, and you cannot end him with him in jail, like, it's just, it's horrible. And did Jordan say, yeah, but that was your idea?
然后我说：“乔丹，这电影太棒了。你绝对不能用这个结局。”我当时就直说了，我没有留余地，我说：“你必须改结局。”我说：“丹尼尔太棒了，所有人都在迷恋他，电影太惊艳了，你绝不能让他以进监狱的方式结束，这太……这太糟糕了。”然后乔丹说：“是啊，但那不是你的主意吗？”
Yeah, he said, yeah, he said, but that was your note. No, he was amazing. You sent me that note from the back of your van. You said you were on Cahuenga. You idiot, you idiot. No, he was a man. No, I pitched him some horrible idea of what it should be to keep him alive.
对，他说：“对啊，但这其实是你的建议。”不，他太棒了。你当时是从你的面包车后面给我发的那条建议。你说你正在卡胡恩加大道上。你个笨蛋，你个笨蛋。不，他是个大男人。不，我当时向他提出了一个极其糟糕的想法，说应该怎么做才能让主角活下来。
So in the originals, she, I forget the name of the character, the girl in it, the lead girl. Alison Williams. Alison Williams. She, I haven't seen her in a long time, but she ends up getting him in jail, is that what it is? I think, now I'm forgetting, but I think the end, he's in jail, he winds up in jail.
所以在原版里，她——我忘了那个角色的名字了，里面的那个女孩，女主角。爱莉森·威廉姆斯。爱莉森·威廉姆斯。她——我好久没看那部电影了，但她最后把他弄进了监狱，是这样吗？我想……现在我有点记不清了，但我觉得结局是他在监狱里，他最后进了监狱。
Like there's a scene of him like in jail. Wow, yeah, it's so good how it is. It's like so sad. And Jordan, you know, a month later, he had a new idea for the end, he reshot it. What a filmmaker he is. Amazing filmmaker. Amazing filmmaker.
就像有他在监狱里的那种镜头。哇，对啊，现在的结局太棒了。那种感觉太悲凉了。而乔丹呢，你懂的，一个月后他就想出了一个新的结局，然后重拍了。他真是一位优秀的电影人。了不起的电影人。了不起的电影人。
Amazing. Tell me your favorite horror film. Oh, just a softball right here at the end. and he reshot it and it's like an amazing film maker. Tell me your favorite horror film. Oh, just a softball right here at the end. Yeah, just so we can alienate everybody he works with, other than the person he names. Any funny stories of you going up on a line on stage? I like Hitchcock movies, those are my favorite, in terms of like, those are my inspiration movies.
太棒了。告诉我你最喜欢的恐怖片是什么。哦，最后来这么一个轻松好答的问题。他重拍了，这简直是一位了不起的电影人。告诉我你最喜欢的恐怖片是什么。哦，最后来这么一个轻松好答的问题。对，好让我们把跟他合作过的所有人都得罪光——除了他点名的人以外。你有没有在舞台上忘词的搞笑故事？我喜欢希区柯克的电影，那些是我的最爱，就……它们是我的灵感来源。
Yeah. Okay, so listen, you gotta get outta here. We gotta get outta here. What Blumhouse movies are we gonna go to, are people gonna come and see in 2025? Tell us right now. He just did. Well, I did.
好吧，听着，你得走了。我们得结束了。2025年有哪些布伦屋的电影上映，大家会去看？现在就告诉我们。他刚刚已经说过了。嗯，我是说过了。
Wolfman is January, it's great. It's Lee Wanell who did The Invisible Man. It's amazing. Is that Julia Garner? Julia Garner and Chris Abbott. Yeah, and it's great. So Wolfman is-El who did The Invisible Man. It's amazing. Is that Julia Garner? Julia Garner and Chris Abbott. Yeah, and it's great. Okay, so Wolfman is January, okay. Wolfman is January.
《狼人》是一月上映，非常棒。导演是拍过《隐形人》的雷·沃纳尔。太棒了。主演是朱莉娅·加纳吗？朱莉娅·加纳和克里斯·阿伯特。对，而且非常棒。所以《狼人》是——导演是拍过《隐形人》的雷·沃纳尔。太棒了。主演是朱莉娅·加纳吗？朱莉娅·加纳和克里斯·阿伯特。对，而且非常棒。好吧，所以《狼人》是一月，好的。《狼人》是一月。
This original movie by Chris Landon who did Happy Death Day. Michael Landon's son. Michael Landon's son called Drop with Megan Fahey, which is great. Drop. And then we have Megan II. Megan II. At the summer release.
这部原创电影由执导过《忌日快乐》的克里斯·兰登执导。迈克尔·兰登的儿子。迈克尔·兰登的儿子，片名叫《夺命直播》（Drop），主演是梅根·费伊，非常棒。《夺命直播》。然后我们有《梅根2》。《梅根2》。暑期上映。
Summer release. Then we have Black Phone Two. Black Phone Two. That's Scott Derrickson with the Great Ethan Hawke. Back is the grabber. Back is the grabber. I thought they caught him. Then we have Five Nights at Freddy's Two.
暑期上映。然后我们有《黑色电话2》。《黑色电话2》。那是斯科特·德瑞克森执导，还有伟大的伊桑·霍克。绑匪又回来了。绑匪又回来了。我以为他们抓住他了呢。然后我们有《玩具熊的五夜后宫2》。
Now clearly you guys missed the first one. Ten Nights at Freddy's. You've got 12 months to see the first and then see the second. Ten Nights at Freddy's. Christmas release. 12 months to see the first and then see the second. 10 Nights at Freddy's. Christmas release? Christmas release. If you're doing the math. December release and our friends at Atomic Monster
显然你们俩连第一部都没看。《玩具熊的十夜后宫》。你们有12个月的时间去看第一部，然后再看第二部。《玩具熊的十夜后宫》。圣诞档上映。有12个月的时间去看第一部，然后再看第二部。《玩具熊的十夜后宫》。圣诞档上映？圣诞档上映。如果你算一下时间的话。十二月上映，而且我们在原子怪兽影业的朋友们
have the next Conjuring movie, have Mortal Kombat. So it's a big year. It's a full slate of great movies. It's a monster year. You should consider doing the year after for Five Nights at Freddy's, do it as a great movie. It's a monster year. You should consider doing the year after for Five Nights at Freddy's. Do it as a Christmas movie, 12 Nights at Freddy's, tied into Christmas.
还有下一部《招魂》电影，还有《真人快打》。所以今年是个大年。有很多精彩的电影排期。这是个怪物级的一年。你应该考虑把《玩具熊的五夜后宫》的下一部留到后年，把它当成一部伟大的电影来做。这是个怪物级的一年。你应该考虑把《玩具熊的五夜后宫》的下一部安排在后年。把它当成圣诞电影来做，叫《玩具熊的十二夜后宫》，跟圣诞节结合起来。
Yeah, it's a great idea. That's a freebie. You're welcome, it's a free one. It's a free one from us to you. Blumhouse is bringing you all the movies you want to see. Go and see them. We urge you, we urge you to go and see them. And you are an unbelievable guest.
对，这主意太棒了。这是一个免费的主意。不客气，这是一个免费的。这是我们送给你的免费点子。布伦屋正在为你带来所有你想看的电影。去看吧。我们强烈敦促你们，强烈敦促你们去看。而你真是一位不可思议的嘉宾。
Well, you're an unbelievable guy. It took me four years,, it was a lot of fun. You're an unbelievable guy. It took me four years, but there was a lot of pressure. I had to make it worth it. Fuck, you delivered. Thank you, guys. You delivered. Thank you for having me. Jason, you're the best.
好吧，你也是个不可思议的家伙。我花了四年时间……这真的很有趣。你真是个不可思议的家伙。我花了四年时间，但压力确实很大。我必须得对得起这等待。操，你真的做到了。谢谢你们，伙计们。你们太棒了。谢谢你们邀请我。杰森，你最棒了。
I appreciate it. Say hi to Lauren, please. Okay, I will. Lots of love to all of you. Love you, and congrats, by the way, your new daughter. Thank you, thank you, my little daughter. Bye, buddy. All right, thanks, guys.
我很感激。请替我向劳伦问好。好的，我会的。向你们所有人和家属致以满满的爱。爱你们，顺便恭喜你喜得千金。谢谢，谢谢，我的小女儿。再见，老兄。好的，谢谢你们，伙计们。
Bye, pal. The man is a gift for Gab. You know, we could expand this to four hosts, very easily come in here. But aside from, totally, aside from buying a movie from him, I would buy a house from him. I know. Yeah. I'd let him shovel my driveway.
再见，老兄。这家伙真是个社交达人。你知道的，我们完全可以把节目扩展到四个主持人，轻轻松松就能坐到这里来。但抛开别的……完全抛开从他那儿买电影不说，我都想从他手里买套房子。我懂。对啊。我都愿意让他帮我铲车道上的雪。
Yeah. I'd let him shovel my driveway. I'd let him fix my wiring. I don't deal with the electric van. No, a very, very good person. And so is his wife. And it's just, I don't know. A good guy.
对啊。我都愿意让他帮我铲车道上的雪。我都愿意让他帮我修理电路。我不搞电车那套。不，他真的是个非常非常好的人。他妻子也是。总之，我不知道。真是个好人。
And a perfect example of how to succeed. You know, like when you're kind of starting out in this business, if there's any young producers out there, it's a perfect person to kind of, you know, look for inspiration of how he did it. I know, but it's like, how would you say, like, you know, he does have, I was trying to break down, like what's the recipe to become Jason Blunt?
这简直是如何取得成功的完美范例。你知道的，当你在这一行刚起步的时候，如果外面有什么年轻制作人的话，他绝对是一个完美的学习榜样，可以从中寻找他是如何做到这一点的灵感。我懂，但这就好像是……你会怎么说呢？你知道的，他确实有……我一直在试图剖析，成为杰森·布伦的秘诀到底是什么？
His personality. I mean, but not to belittle his ability in the business, but people skills is an enormous part of this industry no matter what lane you're in. That's true, and I will say this, and I will say he has the, I was thinking about it too throughout the thing, like what is it that makes him so successful,
他的个性。我是说，倒不是贬低他在业务上的能力，但在无论你身处哪个赛道，人际交往能力都是这个行业极其重要的一部分。确实如此，而且我要这么说，我也一直在琢磨这件事——到底是什么让他如此成功？
other than he says that he's a good picker, he's got tremendous people skills, he understands, but he's really smart. Yeah, you have to be a lot of things. But he's really smart. Yeah. You have to be a lot of things and he's a lot of things. So like it's a good place to start is being really smart. Yeah. You know, JB, nothing?
除了他说自己很会挑剧本之外，他有着极强的人际交往能力，他很有同理心，而且他真的极其聪明。对，你得具备很多品质。但他真的极其聪明。对。你必须具备很多品质，而他恰恰都具备。所以，要想开始的话，首先得具备的一点就是极其聪明。对。你知道的，JB，没事吧？
Huh? Oh, no, I was looking at a text and I thought, are we getting in? Now we know why you're not him. And attentive. Now we know why you're not him. Cause he would never do that. No, no, not at all.
啊？哦，没有，我刚才在看一条短信，然后我在想，我们是不是要进正题了？现在我们知道你为什么不是他了。而且还很专心。现在我们知道你为什么不是他了。因为他绝对不会做那种事。不，不，绝对不会。
Well, Rob Armier, stop fucking texting me while we're doing the wrap up. God damn it. Rob was texting you? We have pickups, we have pickups we have to get to. So let's get to a buy, Sean, you have anything on the list? I don't have anything on the list that fits. Really?
好吧，罗布·阿尔米亚，我们在录收尾的时候别他妈给我发短信了。该死的。罗布给你发短信了？我们有补拍镜头，我们还有得去拍补拍镜头。所以我们进入“购买”环节吧，肖恩，你的清单上有东西吗？我的清单上没有合适的。真的吗？
How about, you know, let's try a new thing. I'm gonna give you a word here that I'd like for you to work into a buy, okay? And the word is buy for Kate. Okay, Will, would you like to go first? We did that one last week, right? Okay, how about? How about a buyback?
要不，你知道的，我们尝试个新花样。我给你出一个词，我希望你能把它用到你的“购买”环节里，好吗？这个词是“为凯特买单（buy for Kate）”。好吧，威尔，你想先来吗？我们上周刚玩过那个，对吧？好吧，那这个呢？回购（buyback）怎么样？
What's a buyback? A buyback. What is a buyback? Somebody with two backs? A buyback would be if you wanted to purchase something back from somebody. Oh, I would never want to do that to one of his films. I would never want to go into his film after seeing something so spectacular and ask for a...
什么是回购？回购。回购是什么？背上有两个包的人？回购就是你想从别人手里把某样东西买回来。哦，我永远不会对他的电影做这种事。在看到如此震撼的作品之后，我绝不会走进他的电影院然后要求……
You would never need to. I would never need to go into his face. I feel like this is going to be really lazy. I would never ask for or need a buyback. I feel like this is gonna be really lazy. I feel like this is really lazy. I would never ask for a knee day. Bye back. Bye. We all even saw it coming. Instead of get out, it could be called bye.
你永远不需要这么做。我绝不需要走进他的面……我觉得这会非常偷懒。我绝不会要求或需要一次回购。我觉得这会非常偷懒。我觉得这真的很偷懒。我绝不会要求一次……回购。再见。我们早就料到了。与其叫《逃出绝命镇》，不如叫《再见》（Bye）。
What's that Michael? Instead of get out, it could be called bye. Bye. There you go. Oh yes. it didn't clear It was already taken what you have the original title for get out was by Smart. Less. SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Michael Grant Terry, Rob Armjarve, and Bennett Barbico.
迈克尔，你说什么？与其叫《逃出绝命镇》，不如叫《再见》。再见。你看。哦，是的。这个没过审。已经被别人注册了。你知道《逃出绝命镇》最初的片名叫什么吗？叫《聪明的劣势》（Smart Less）。《聪明的劣势》100%由迈克尔·格兰特·特里、罗布·阿尔贾夫和本内特·巴比科手工有机制作。
Smart. Less. Smart. Less. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
《聪明的劣势》。《聪明的劣势》。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。